[Music]
welcome to the huberman lab guest Series
where I and an expert guest discuss
science and science-based tools for
everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford school of medicine today marks
the fourth episode in our four episode
series with Dr Paul Conte about Mental
Health
today's episode deals with the topic of
self-care we hear the phrase self-care a
lot nowadays but rarely if ever is
self-care precisely defined for instance
is self-care about pampering oneself is
it about self-acceptance is self-care
about just making sure we get enough
sleep and enough exercise and have
healthy relationships well it turns out
that yes indeed adequate self-care is
about all of those things but true
self-care the topic of today's episode
is about far more as it relates to our
mental health true self-care is also
about constructing a life narrative in
which we frame our past our present and
future in a way that allows us to see
what's gone wrong what's gone right and
the best path to navigate forward so in
many ways true self-care is really about
fostering a sense of self-awareness and
doing so within the context of a
framework that is known to work and
today Dr Paul Conti shares with us
exactly how to do that he also touches
on some of the things that if not
properly understood and processed can
inhibit our ability to take excellent
care of ourselves including how to
properly process traumatic experiences
something that he is expert in among
many other topics as well he also
touches on some of the things that can
potentially serve as barriers to
excellent self-care including traumatic
experiences and explains how to frame
those traumatic experiences so that we
can best move forward he also shares
with us various practices that include
therapy but also practices that we can
carry out on our own such as specific
forms of meditation journaling and other
ways of examining the self and fostering
better self-care toward our mental
health as I mentioned before this is the
fourth episode in our four episode
series all about mental health I realize
that perhaps not everyone has had the
opportunity yet to listen to the
previous three episodes in this series
if you haven't it certainly won't
prevent you from gleaning important
information and protocols from today's
episode but I do encourage you at some
point to try and listen to all four
episodes in this series because at some
level they are interwoven at the level
of concept steps end of practices I'd
also like to highlight that Dr Paul
Conte has generously provided some
simple diagrams that can help you
navigate today's material and the
material in the other episodes they are
available as zero cost PDFs by simply
going to the show note captions where
you can view them or download them
before we begin I'd like to emphasize
that this podcast is separate from my
teaching and research roles at Stanford
it is however part of my desire and
effort to bring zero cost to Consumer
information about science and science
related tools to the general public in
keeping with that theme I'd like to
thank the sponsors of today's podcast
our first sponsor is betterhelp
betterhelp offers Professional Therapy
with a licensed therapist carried out
all online I've been doing therapy for
more than 30 years well I confess that
initially I was forced to do that
therapy as a condition for being let
back into high school over time I
learned that therapy is a tremendously
valuable practice in fact I consider
doing regular weekly therapy as just as
important as doing regular physical
exercise in order to improve one's
Health the beauty of better help is that
it makes it extremely easy to find a
therapist that's excellent for you and
we can define an excellent therapist as
somebody who's going to give you a lot
of support but in an objective way as
well as somebody with whom you can have
excellent Rapport and that can help you
arrive at positively transformative
insights that you wouldn't have
otherwise had and with better help they
make it convenient so that it's matched
to your schedule and the other aspects
of your life if you'd like to try better
help go to betterhelp.com huberman to
get 10 off your first month again that's
betterhelp help help.com huberman
today's episode is also brought To Us by
waking up waking up is a meditation app
that offers dozens of guided meditation
sessions mindfulness trainings yoga need
recessions and more
by now there's an abundance of data
showing that even short daily
meditations can greatly improve our mood
reduce anxiety improve our ability to
focus and can improve our memory and
while there are many different forms of
meditation most people find it difficult
to find and stick to a meditation
practice in a way that is most
beneficial for them the waking up app
makes it extremely easy to learn how to
meditate and to carry out your daily
meditation practice in a way that's
going to be most effective and efficient
for you it includes a variety of
different types of meditations of
different duration as well as things
like Yoga Nidra which place the brain
and body into a sort of pseudo sleep
that allows you to emerge feeling
incredibly mentally refreshed in fact
the science around Yoga Nidra is really
impressive showing that after a Yoga
Nidra session levels of dopamine in
certain areas of the brain are enhanced
by up to 60 percent which places the
brain and body into a state of enhanced
Readiness for mental work and for
physical work another thing I really
like about the waking up app is that it
provides a 30 day a introduction course
so for those of you that have not
meditated before or getting back to a
meditation practice that's fantastic or
if you're somebody who's already a
skilled and regular meditator waking up
has more advanced meditations and yoga
need your sessions for you as well if
you'd like to try the waking up app you
can go to wakingup.com huberman and
access a free 30-day trial again that's
wakingup.com huberman and now for my
discussion about mental health with Dr
Paul Conte Dr Conti welcome back thank
you pleasure to be here for this series
we've been focusing on mental health and
really defining what mental health is
and a road map to achieve mental health
and in episode one you laid out for us a
map essentially of the things that any
and all of us can look at
pretty much at any time with essentially
any degree of resources to try and get a
better understanding of ourselves and
how well or not well we happen to be
moving toward or creating true mental
health for ourselves in addition to that
you spelled out for us what true mental
health really is and just to recap a
little bit of that it really boils down
to these verb States action states of
agency and gratitude yes
and then in episode 2 you covered some
of the common challenges that you've
observed in life and in your clinical
practice and we address some of the ways
that people can overcome those
challenges by going to the map opening
the so-called cupboards as we're
referring to them and asking specific
sorts of questions
and then in episode three we talked
about how looking at the map and
exploring the map in those Cupboards in
particular can help people in relational
aspects of Life romantic relationship
work relationships family relationships
and the relationship to self yes very
important very important the foundation
of all relationships outside of
ourselves and I'm so glad that you
highlighted the relationship to self
because today's episode we will of
course return to the map and I should
mention that if people have not seen
episodes one two or three that's okay
today's discussion will be entirely
accessible to them but I do recommend
that at some point they especially
listen to episode one and hopefully
episodes two and three as well
but today's discussion is really about
the aspects of ourselves that exist in
all people
and the action steps the paths of
inquiry that are available to all people
that can allow anyone and everyone to
improve their Mental Health
to move toward these ideals of agency
and gratitude on a regular basis yes and
as you pointed out it is a process it's
not that we arrive at agency and
gratitude and just to reiterate agency
and gratitude are verb States they
involve ways of being in the world right
they're active processes like life is an
active process right there's not an end
point we're trying to reach right we're
trying to live
and in thinking about today's discussion
you know it occurred to both of us
really that today's discussion is really
about self-care you know self-care as a
concept I think for many people evokes
Notions of like okay you're gonna take a
vacation or you're going to kick your
feet up or uh get a massage you know
things of that sort and certainly it can
involve those sorts of things but just
as if we were having a discussion about
physical health and we're going to talk
about ways to take care of the physical
body to enhance Health span and lifespan
today's discussion is really about how
to take care of the internal landscape
the Mind Right which also qualifies very
strongly as self-care yes
so if you would could you tell us how
you think about self-care you know
regardless of whether or not you have a
patient who's dealing with severe mental
illness or somebody who's just you know
hitting the same speed bumps of Life
over and over again or anything in
between you know what sorts of self-care
practices and mindsets do you suggest
people
take on for themselves and for that
matter how do you think about self-care
right well I think we start with with
factors that are really just Baseline
factors uh that have to be in place in
order to achieve good things upon them
so the basics of you know we have to be
eating well enough to feel okay and
hopefully eating really well we have to
stay hydrated we have to get sleep we
have to move the body I mean these are
Basics but Basics a lot of people are
not attending to similarly we have to be
in a situation that isn't making fear
and misery all the time so an example of
an abusive relationship right a person
has to be has to navigate out of that
before they can really start taking care
of themselves in the way that builds
goodness right so so we look for the
basic factors that we need to take care
of in order to then look at the factors
that become particular to each of us and
what we're really looking for is
self-understanding right how much can we
understand about ourselves be
knowledgeable about what's going on
inside of us why it's going on also and
very importantly being aware that we
don't know everything that goes on
inside of us and being curious about
that and looking at how we're engaging
with the world around us or do we feel
happy do we not feel happy how do we
Define what happy Means how are we
engaging with the world because as you
were saying the agency and gratitude are
verb state so how are we living life how
are we engaging with the world do we
feel like life is a sequence of things I
have to do you know for example right or
are we doing things we really really
don't want to do right do we have to do
those things how could life be different
right we start looking at ourselves to
to assess how we're engaging with
ourselves the people the world around us
in a way that is either generative or
not generative if we're in that state of
agency and gratitude then we are going
to have periods of time where we feel
peaceful right we feel a sense of
contentment or we feel delighted so is
any of that in my life right if not why
can I start thinking about that
sometimes the answer is quite clear like
oh there's this thing I love and I'm not
doing that right and and I can't do it
and then you revisit like is it true
that you can't do it I mean a lot of
times it is not true and if it is true
how does the person come to terms with
that process that perhaps grieve right
so say if it's a loss of a person right
that can keep people you know in
terrible misery over years and years so
there may be things we have to
understand we have to process so that we
can get ourselves to that place of
knowing ourselves pretty well and
engaging in the world in ways that we
have a pretty good understanding of and
that that are adaptive and then we look
to say okay now how do I make that
better because now we're thinking about
preventive medicine right we want our
bodies to be healthy because of course
we want to be healthy today right but we
also don't know what will happen in the
future right will there be an injury or
an illness I mean eventually like you
know we all have an injury or an illness
in some way or another so we're
preparing for the predictable challenges
that will come our way in the future and
we're well served by doing this about
our mental health too right there will
be challenges that come our way there
will be losses and stressors and things
that make us feel bad or feel scared I
mean these things will happen to us so
the healthier we are the better today is
and the better we set ourselves up to
either make tomorrow even better today
or if tomorrow gives me a challenge I
don't have today I can meet that
challenge and get back to a better place
so if I understand correctly it sounds
like one of the cornerstones of
self-care for sake of mental health
involves asking really good questions
about oneself yes
yes I don't think I've ever heard it
defined that way before yes you know um
it's in such stark contrast to the other
forms of self-care which I certainly
subscribe to as well like making sure
one gets enough rest and
um you know avoids toxic people to the
extent one can Etc or toxic environments
uh and so on right you mentioned ask
questions of the self but but the The
Logical next question to that is well
what questions do I ask myself sometimes
we know we have an idea right sometimes
we don't and this is where the
construction of a life narrative like
let me think about my life let me
potentially talk about my life with a
trusted other person let me potentially
write down a narrative about my life and
we can learn so much from doing that so
the person who thinks back and starts to
tell a story of themselves and let's say
just as an example you know that story
is is going pretty well and the person
is feeling pretty good about themselves
and then say something happens and it
starts to change well then this thing
happened and then you know I started
kind of spending time with different
people or I started dating different
people or I took a different kind of job
and and it can engender the reflection
of like oh like things really kind of
changed then because because the emotion
systems within us don't care about the
clock or the calendar the emotions often
of negative experiences can backmap into
our lives and someone who can tell you I
was miserable ever since I was a child
can then write out a life narrative that
describes a very happy childhood until
something happened or something changed
at a certain point which could be
something dramatic or it might be
increasing pressures of school or
increasing social pressures or how
things changed at puberty right and if
we have an understanding of that we may
know the right questions like for
example let's say afterwards the person
finds that they're drinking more so an
example with a common example instead of
taking that for granted oh that's what I
do right or yeah I can't cope any better
right the negative things people will
say to themselves The Narrative can
often point out I can cope better I did
cope better I did feel differently about
myself so the the life narrative can
really help us establish the road map
right and part of what the life
narrative does is it guides us to the
places to ask the questions
if you would be so kind as to tell us a
little bit more about how one would do
this on their own so does this involve
journaling things out I confess I have a
file on my computer uh that has a bunch
of other files that starts with you know
age zero to five and then I have some
notes in there it's not an autobiography
far from it it's just kind of highlights
of events that I remember you know six
to ten and so on and places I lived and
I use it just to kind of Orient myself
in time yes
um I actually don't know what the the
purpose and utility of it is or why I
initially started doing this but it's an
important file to me and when I return
to it I often remember additional key
events so it's constantly growing I mean
the these files are getting quite large
again with no specific uh purpose of
writing this out at any point but just
to orient right right you you can't not
learn about yourself
from doing that right it exposes truths
of self it makes you ponder about things
it draws your attention to ways in which
you've changed whether you think those
ways are good or bad right it draws your
attention to change it draws your
attention to the impact of external
events and as you said it sort of it
grounds you it provides a way of
localizing oneself in time like I am
here now
wait how did I get here right and and
the thoughts and ideas of how we got
here very much help us because often we
don't do that you know we're sort of
rushing headlong forward because in many
ways our society is prompting us we live
in a very fast moving society and we
want information and gratification and
often we don't even want it very fast
but it's coming at us very fast anyway
and to stop and reflect makes a very
very big difference even even to think
at times Beyond Our Generations right
into the best of my knowledge the vast
majority of people on one side of my
family everyone was a Shepherd for like
every generation until like two ago
right and thinking about that of like
huh that's interesting right it makes me
a mainly is grateful so grateful for the
opportunity I've had but I also think
like well they lived in close-knit
communities then and what was that like
and you know we begin to see ourselves
in a broader way both in our own history
and then projecting forward which which
sometimes is about children and
nurturing children but it can certainly
be about other things it can be about
friendship it can be about work so we
start to see ourselves in ways that are
interesting that are through the lens of
Truth and that speak to our place in the
world around us and I think this
engenders both agency and gratitude
right if I'm aware of like what have I
done what have I accomplished when
haven't I accomplished things how might
that be different and and a sense of
gratitude for being here and having
opportunity and even be able to think
about this you know my guess is when you
read through those files that at some
points you have a sense of Marvel well
like whoa that's me right whether it's a
good memory or it's a difficult memory
no it's all part of you that leads you
through to today and you do have a
better sense of self through that
and one of the feelings I most often
come away from those excursions into
those files with is one of gratitude
because so much of what's in those files
um are Recollections of others that I
really appreciate some are still alive
some aren't and
um what that's meant to me and how that
carries me forward so yeah so that's
what I do
um I I'm sure there are a near infinite
number of ways that people could do this
but what are a few that you've seen work
really well
um that people can do on their own or
perhaps with a clinician as well in fact
that raises the question should people
share this sort of practice and the
contents of that practice with with a
trusted clinician right right yeah I
think sharing within with another person
always should be a trusted other right
and we can kind of take stock of that
you know of people have an idea of who
may be safe right often people so
there's no one I could share something
with but really that often comes through
lens of fear you know of exposure self
of rejection of vulnerability which
often is warranted but sometimes is not
sometimes there really are in fact often
there are safe people right so the
the act of doing something other than
just thinking about something brings as
you all know it brings parts of our
brain online that then are thinking in a
different way so for example they may
bring error correction mechanisms online
so if I'm thinking over and over again
that I've never been good enough to do
anything you know that can be just
automatic inside of me but if I start to
write or to talk or even to formulate
words to talk to myself or to put words
in my mind as if I were talking now we
come at it in a different way and we we
can sort of ferret out the truth within
us which might be you know it's not true
that I've never been able to do things
or achieve things and and people often
bring that online by doing something
other than the same thought process
that's gone often over and over and it's
non-productive and it brings down mood
and it raises anxiety and it also builds
a sense of futility I mean I cannot tell
you how often I've heard a person say
like no good will come of this or like
okay try it we'll try but I know I can't
be I've been thinking about this for 10
years or 20 years but what they've been
doing is the same thing they've been
ruminating on it for 10 years they start
talking about it and and people will say
oh my goodness like I I've achieved more
in two hours you know than I than I did
in years right but that's because you're
doing something different
in the two hours so I think that's very
important especially because we can't
say okay go look in your unconscious
mind and see what you find there right
so then we need ways of accessing the
unconscious mind and the communication
either with self in writing with others
can be very very helpful in doing that I
also I am a firm believer that knowledge
is power many times I I will feel like
I've I'll have a sense of really having
helped someone and the other person may
have that sense and we can see the
change and all that I've done is impart
knowledge right we all know different
things so often it's the case that hey I
happen to have learned things that are
different from what that other person
learns and then I'm communicating to
them things that I have learned so they
know them too and then they feel
tremendously better
right because if we put inside of
ourselves the tools of understanding our
unconscious minds and sometimes our
conscious minds too will work on them
we'll make use of them so so if you talk
to a person for example about how trauma
can impact Us and how we can shove it
underneath the surface and how it can
spin off shame then that person may take
that knowledge away and come back with
real understanding and the fact that we
can do this on our own right we can do
this through good resources we can do
this by taking information into
ourselves that can be very very helpful
and it doesn't require because the first
place to start are with things we can do
that don't require professional help
right and and sometimes we may come at
problems that that do tell us that we
should get professional help right so if
we're having thoughts of self-harm
thoughts of not wanting to be alive
thoughts of real despair thoughts of
real of hopelessness that's telling us
okay let's get some help there's a role
in a place for professional help but
people come to professional help in
other ways too such as for example
reflecting on the self and and it's a
real example person thinking you know
I really became kind of different when
you know when things started changing
like after college and then I thought
like oh I've kind of gotten to this
place and I've got a good job and like
things really should get better
but like they kind of haven't right and
that was really a branch point that
person may have never really thought
about that or they may have thought
about it ten thousand times and then
shoved it underneath from from
Consciousness to unconsciousness because
it's a scary vulnerability inducing
thing it seems scary like how could it
be that I achieved things it didn't get
healthier now we're afraid of that right
and and letting that come to the surface
being able to say oh like that's true
like I don't have to be afraid to shine
light on that then a lot of times that
alone sometimes a person will solve
their own problems they think about it
they come in they have all the answers
they thank me I did nothing but listen
but the listening part is important it
allowed them to come in and say what
they needed to say and other times then
it's not it can be that but it's not
always that other times it informs us
about what to work on clinically and it
might not be something that's dire right
it might just be like I want to
understand this I want to be happier I
want to be healthier I want to work
towards these good things when people
talk about that there are always if you
really distill down what are they
talking about sense of Peace a sense of
contentment coming at the world through
agency and gratitude and and we can do
that through self-inquiry including
through therapy it doesn't have to just
be for situations where oh there's a
significant clinical problem
is it the case that when somebody
journals a bit of their life narrative
or thinks about some
great or
sadly traumatic events that perhaps
happen to them at whatever stage of life
that there's something accomplished in
that action or in that therapy session
if they're doing it with a clinician but
that when they go to sleep that night
and perhaps in their waking States as
well that the unconscious is working
some of that through such that you know
Revelations come to mind later insights
come to mind
um you know I'm certainly familiar with
the fact that there are certain times of
day and evening where my brain is in a
bit of a liminal state it feels like
somewhere between sleep and awake and I
just have learned that provided I block
against outside sensory input as much as
I can in particular social media and the
news that I'll just be you know doing
the dishes or preparing coffee or
something and something will come to
mind seemingly out of nowhere right it's
not always a great Insight in fact it's
rarely a great Insight but it always
takes me a bit by surprise sometimes a
little bit of delight sometimes a little
bit of shock like wow like where did
that come from because it came from your
unconscious mind right it was invisible
to you then it got thrown up and you're
like whoa and you realize it while in
the midst of doing something relatively
mundane right because during the day
you're engaging your brain is highly
engaged which is great but it doesn't
leave a lot of room right for the
unconscious mind to do its millions and
millions of things a second that can
help you figure things out which is the
same reason it's uncanny any any
psychiatrist will tell you this that
that people a person will come in and
say it's strange you know all of a
sudden when when I can finally relax
like that's when I have a panic attack
right or they don't know like then I can
finally relax I go ah and then my
heart's beating fast and I'm sweating
right because that's when the panic
attacks come if the person is laboring
under something that is is causing them
there's a constant distress when when
you stop focusing outward and you sort
of settle into an inward State then the
things that are underneath the surface
are going to come to the surface and if
there's something really bothering you
that your brain is very upset about or
very afraid of what does it throw up to
the surface a panic attack right but if
you're in a good place you're taking
care of yourself you're in a generative
stage you're in a safe environment then
when you you stop putting all the
attention outward so we imagine then
salience changes and instead of a lot of
the salience being outward it starts to
be Inward and you just sort of
meditative you're washing the dishes
right and there's room then for your
unconscious mind to throw something
important to the surface it's the exact
opposite of how people can't remember
something if they're trying to think of
it I mean we all go through this oh I
can't remember that person's name or
that restaurant or whatever it is try to
keep thinking about it and see if you
figure it out right the answer is not in
your conscious mind so if you keep
bringing your conscious mind to Bear you
just generate frustration right but then
when you stop thinking bad the answer is
there inside of you oh I remember now
right so so that's how if we if we have
the conscious mind engage in something
it's not going to figure out right then
it doesn't figure the thing out right
and and that works for our problems too
that's why a person can say I thought
about that for 10 years now you're
ruminated about it for 10 years it just
ran over and over and over in the
conscious mind and how ironic right it
prevents
understanding
so it's very clear to me that asking
certain kinds of questions about oneself
and one's self-narrative you know life
history essentially can be very
beneficial in the moment or moments of
doing that practice as well as the
subconscious or I guess the appropriate
way to refer to it as the unconscious
right okay so for those out there who
like me sometimes say subconscious it's
unconscious uh
the unconscious can throw things up to
the surface that can be real insights
can can give us not just panic attacks
which I think most people would like to
shy away from but as you point out
there's information in the fact that the
panic attack is occurring under right
conditions and if you stir up the pot of
the unconscious and you put some new
information in it can do new things it
can figure new things out which is why
the process of self-reflection for
example and often the process of therapy
is not always and in fact often is not a
pleasant process right but then we take
away from that hard work renewed
insights so someone this happens all the
time who knows they know that a certain
trauma is inside of them and has been
affecting them whether it's for days or
weeks or years they know it they don't
know what to do about it they have a
conflict about it so they keep trying to
shove it under the surface and they they
finally accept for whatever reason to
talk about it and and what often happens
then is let's say doing three or four
successive weeks of hourly therapy I
mean that person is crying and that
person is upset or a person is angry I
mean it doesn't always happen this way
but it does a fair amount of the time as
they get better and better right because
they're discharging some of the energy
right maybe they're crying and they're
sad because they're grieving something
they haven't grieved before right
because they've just been angry right or
they've just been ashamed a classic
example is a death I mean how many times
do people think well that can't be still
affecting me it was X number of years
ago but they've never actually grieved
because they carry in them oh it was my
fault right and and how many times do we
hear that I should have said something
different before I should have gone you
know we then back map something that
makes us feel bad and then from the
guilt and shame comes the inability to
process grief
so if the person then deals with right I
feel so bad about this in fact I feel so
ashamed of it and I feel like it's my
fault and so okay well let's talk about
that right after my after my brother's
death by Suicide I felt responsible I I
was not involved in any way in mental
health I had a business career at the
time and I finally went and saw someone
I wasn't acculturated that getting
therapy was something one did but I
realized hey I'm not okay right so I
didn't know I didn't know how right I
just knew the manifestation of it which
was misery and risk and you know I I
could just tell like I know what it
feels like to not feel like this and
this is not okay so so then I you know I
called the insurance number eventually I
go in and and see a therapist and you
know she did I'm sure she was a very
good therapist but she didn't in the
sense need to be in the sense that
sometimes we don't need to use all the
things we know we can do just something
basic with someone and that's all she
did with me she got me talking about it
and then I talked about how ashamed I
was because it was my fault and then
really and then she challenged me about
that and then you know in a nice way but
then it was became clear that I was so
utterly shocked by it right far from it
being foreseeable to me right that that
the problem that I was having now was
the shock of it and the the sense of
Shame and guilt that it raised in me and
then me shoving it under the surface not
knowing what to do with it then it's
making all sorts of misery in me and I
can't actually grieve right so at some
point during those sessions now I'm sad
and I'm crying right and and I know what
she was thinking right she's good okay
this is like this thank goodness this
person getting better she probably felt
a sense of relief because she could say
hey he's he's coming out of risk he's
able to feel sadness he's able to grieve
he's been doing this before you know so
it's it's that it's that work wait if we
put into it that makes a difference just
as in physical health I mean if I want
to be stronger I want to be more robust
like I have to go to the gym and work or
I have to do something that's that's
hard work and then I get the benefit of
it and the same is true whether we're
reflecting on our life narrative and it
brings you know some difficult emotions
to us or whether we're talking with
someone or whether we're doing it in
therapy but that's how that that process
of inquiry leads us you know to take
some of the gordian knots in us so to
speak and and to cut them instead of
trying to figure out like how am I going
to feel okay about myself even though
I'm responsible for my brother's death
because I should have foreseen it I mean
that doesn't work right you have to I
see what that thing is and that that has
to go away right and then therapy can
lead us to the point where it wasn't my
fault then oh my goodness I'm sad
I'd like to take a brief break and
acknowledge one of our sponsors ag-1 ag1
is a vitamin mineral probiotic drink
that meets all of your foundational
nutrition needs I started taking ag1 way
back in 2012. so I'm delighted that
they're sponsoring the podcast the
reason I started taking ag1 and the
reason I still take ag1 once or
generally twice per day is that it's the
easiest way for me to ensure that I'm
getting all of the vitamins minerals
probiotics and fiber that I need in my
diet now of course it's essential to get
proper nutrition from Whole Foods but
most people including myself find it
hard to get enough servings of fruits
and vegetables each day and especially
to get enough prebiotics and probiotics
to ensure gut health as you may know
your gut contains trillions of little
microbiota the so-called gut microbiome
which establishes critical connections
with other organs of your body to
enhance brain health as well as to
support your immune system and other
aspects that relate to mental and
physical health one of the most common
questions I get is if you were to take
Just One supplement which supplement
would that be in my the answer is always
ag1 because by taking ag1 I'm able to
ensure that I'm getting all of the
vitamins minerals and probiotics that I
need to enhance my mental health
physical health and performance if you'd
like to try ag1 go to drinkag1.com
huberman to claim a special offer
they'll give you five free travel packs
and they'll give you a year's supply of
vitamin D3 K2 again that's drinkag1.com
huberman to claim this special offer
I can see how self-inquiry is really
powerful I've certainly experienced that
in my own life and it's an ongoing
process right this is not something that
one does and then stops ideally you do
it forever just like physical fitness
and at the same time I know that a
number of people
perhaps are wary of self-inquiry
especially because of the pain points it
can bring about and make conscious and
that we have to really sit with and most
people would like to avoid discomfort
um I'm sure there are also people who
are doing quite well in life and
therefore think oh you know pattern or
self-inquiry all it could do it sounds
like is more harm like why would I want
to do that but I think we both agree
that there's nothing but
good and progress and more agency and
gratitude to be had by going through
patterns of self-inquiry I think that
really highlights something very
important which is that self-inquiry
isn't always the right answer now I
think just because things are going well
that doesn't mean self-inquiry isn't the
right thing to do self inquiry is always
the right thing to do if we want to
understand ourselves better unless we're
in a place where it can bring real risk
to us so when I was trying to think
about myself in choir why was I so
miserable what's going on in me I mean I
reached a point where I was like I'm not
I'm not getting myself anywhere and I'm
getting worse and like this is now this
is not good for me because where do they
self-inquiry lead me to more guilt and
shame so then at some point I sort of
pulled the rip cord right on it's like I
can't do this on my own anymore right
and and that's very very important to
anyone who's listening if you feel like
look I don't think I'm in a safe or a
stable place again thoughts of self-harm
thoughts of hopelessness then then it
probably is not or let's err on the side
of being cautious right it is not a good
idea then to engage in self-inquiry
right first go see someone clinically
right and I know that can be hard to do
in the this day and age but if we really
advocate for ourselves we really push
you know we really you know we we do
whatever we can do to try and get in
front of someone who can kind of help us
understand what we may need and maybe
that person helps us with the process of
self-inquiry maybe that person reassures
us maybe that person then tells us that
we we really do need you know more care
more help and then it leads to us
getting that so that we can come back to
the good place of being well enough for
the self-inquiry
I'm grateful you shared your path to
working with a clinician and the fact
that just focusing on something on your
own wasn't really working and there was
a it sounds like a requirement for a
clinician to help guide you through that
um it relates directly to
um what I'm most curious about at this
moment which is you know in the map that
you established for us in episode one
and that has carried through all these
episodes and and by the way if people
are not familiar with the map we will
cover it um in top Contour in a little
bit more depth in a moment here but one
of the key things as or cupboards as
we're referring to them uh to look in in
order to exert self-care and improve
one's mental health is this notion of
self-awareness of really understanding
that there's an an eye a me and
exploring what that's really about in
the moment but also historically through
narrative Etc
also in this map is a cupboard that
relates to salience what's most obvious
or what do we default to both internally
in terms of what sorts of thoughts we
default to and externally what are we
focusing on in the outside world and I
think I and perhaps many other people
out there are wondering how to resolve
any conflict between a practice that is
aimed at increasing self-awareness and
perhaps even drawing to mind early
traumas or challenges or recent traumas
or challenges and salience in other
words
if I were to you know take some moments
or even an hour once a week and sit
there and really like think about
the sorts of things that I don't want to
think about like that that have been
annawing at me below the surface for a
very long time the stuff that I you know
gained some proficiency at pushing down
beneath the surface I think one fear
that I have and so I have to assume
other people have it as well is that if
I were to bring that to mind that it
would
overtake a lot of my waking hours like
it's like I don't want to think about
this thing or those things and so now
what Salient is something negative and
when I'm focused on something negative
then I'm not able to be as generative as
I would like you know move my life move
forward toward my life goals now I I
could even have the realization the the
cognitive understanding that okay that's
but that's necessary right like this is
like getting a a wound fixed or or
dealing with a with a chronic injury
like sooner or later you got to deal
with it otherwise you're not going to be
at your best but that
um conflict between gaining more
self-awareness and also the
understanding that what is most Salient
to us is kind of defines the quality of
our daily life
um that that conflict or friction
um seems like an important thing for us
to drill into a little bit absolutely
and I would say this if you think
there's something that you can't bring
up into Consciousness because it's going
to take over your mind or as people
often say I'm going to curl up in a
fetal position I'm going to cry and
never stop that is exactly the thing you
might just look at because salience
presents itself in a whole array of ways
so if there's something inside of you
that's that's strong enough right that
it's throwing itself up to the surface
like hey maybe you want to think about
me right so your unconscious mind
throwing it up to the surface that is
active in you and often although a lot
of it happens in the unconscious mind it
happens also in the conscious mind and
if the person then stops and thinks how
much might that thing that you are not
thinking about be impacting you how
might it be Salient in other ways and
sometimes a person will realize like
yeah that's on my mind people say oh
that's on my mind yeah all the time it's
like kind of on the back burner but
always there and he says right on the
back burner you know that's like having
a voice in the background telling you
something you know very negative or very
distressing and it's just one example
where we're often times there's a
realization that that thing is actually
quite Salient sometimes there isn't a
realization until later oh the salience
of that is that I that's how that's why
I don't let myself get ahead right it
can come out later because you know we
don't know how much of it is unconscious
how much of it is conscious but but
under the right circumstances if things
are safe as we said if there's not
something going on that presents risk
and warrants clinical care if there's
something inside of you and you think I
can't let that to the surface then what
that is telling you is I must let that
to the surface now again we want to do
it in judicious ways and do it in ways
that are safe but that's that's the
message
I think it's especially important that
you mentioned that if something is
gnawing at our conscious mind every once
in a while then it absolutely has to be
operating below the level of our
conscious awareness maybe running amok
all the time level of Consciousness yes
so if ever there was a
um uh cause for exploring something like
that
um that's it right because we can't be
aware of the ways that's damaging to us
or limiting us again you know somebody
listening to this could be doing quite
well the thing I'm doing great like why
would I want to do any of this well uh
perhaps they could be doing that much
better right absolutely
self-awareness and addressing one's
personal narrative and a sense of I is
what we called cupboard one under the
function of self now for those that
listen to episodes one two or three
they'll be familiar with what I'm
talking about when I say a cupboard
cupboard one function of self but
um just for sake of getting everybody on
the same page as we move forward here
maybe we could just return to the map of
mental health uh for a moment you know
we've talked about agency and gratitude
as verb States and you also described in
previous episodes this key really
essential concept of this generative
Drive yes so if you could just take a
few minutes for us and really explain
what agency and gratitude are how one
goes about building those up and
expressing those and what the generative
Drive is and then we'll return to the 10
cupboards of inquiry under the structure
of self and function of self which
really represent the pillars and and all
the stuff that geysers up into uh these
simple but extremely powerful Concepts
and ways of being which are agency and
gratitude yes yes so I I really liked
when you you brought the image of a
geyser right to mind because if we think
about the structure of self which is one
pillar and the function of self which is
another pillar underneath those pills
dollars there are the 10 cupboards we've
been talking about and they represent
the areas of inquiry for us because
they're the aspects of the structure and
function of self so that's where the
answers are right the answers are in
those pillars the answers are in those
10 cupboards so if we're doing that
we're looking there we're honoring what
we find there we're becoming healthier
than that geyser right I imagine it
coming out you know like the space in
between the pillars right and and what
it is lifting up is first empowerment
and humility but empowerment and
humility are qualities it's certainly
the way and the way we're using them
their quality is their potential so I
have empowerment as opposed to being
disempowered right so I have humility
instead of for example a reactive
grandiosity or even a reactive
self-oppression right so I have these
qualities of empowerment and humility
and then they become enacted right they
become expressed by us and I imagine
writing on the top is the agency and the
Gratitude is at the top of the geyser
and it's moving right they're verbs we
navigate life as life moves forward
right I will often think like being on
like the the luge right and you see in
the Olympics so it's going down the
twisting path and it's like that's us
moving through life right and we all
have different Pathways but they can
interconnect and they can cross but
that's what's happening living is an
active thing right so agency and
gratitude are active things why because
they're the ultimate expression of all
underneath of it of them that's where it
goes if the pillars are in the right
place the geyser can function the
empowerment in humility are with us so
we're engaging with ourselves with
others with the world through a lens of
clarity and through a lens of knowing we
can make the world a better place and
knowing our role in it that's very very
active and then it brings to us the
peace the contentment the Delight that
weaves in and out as you described that
you will feel the peace the contentment
the Delight when you're doing the solo
podcasts right but you're doing
something very very active right that
that's not
um it's not a passive Endeavor right
during which you feel all those things
but that makes sense right peace doesn't
mean nothingness right now it can
someone who's looking out the window at
the Garden they planted can feel that
too but but there's life going on in
them also right they're contemplating
the garden they know that they made the
garden so these are all active processes
because life is an active process and
then we end up in this place of looking
inside of us these drives within us are
both deterministic and determined right
so think about about how active a
process that is where we have a natural
bias one way or another because of our
genetics just like someone has a natural
aptitude to be taller in someone shorter
or to be more or less athletic right we
have potential within us when the
genetics come together right and and
that may determine some sort of set of
parameters so so maybe someone who
doesn't have the the blessings of being
so athletic perhaps myself right right
I'm not going to be the world's greatest
athlete right but if I work hard like I
could be a lot more athletic and have
been at times right and if I don't I
could be a lot less athletic right so so
there are potentials within us that get
sort of genetically determined but have
a wide array of uh of variance around
them and then our choices determine
where we are in that variance if I don't
take care of myself I will be on the
very low end of the athletic Spectrum
right if I do and I cultivate myself you
know I can be on a higher end for me
right but still that's a lot better than
the lower end there's a very big
difference the same is true in our
drives so so the more we're taking care
of ourselves we're reinforcing the
Primacy of the generative drive and then
the aggression assertion proactive that
drive in US is realized as best we're
going to realize it and not everyone's
is going to be off the chart right and
that's okay right but but that drive is
in a place it lets that person take care
of themselves you know have a job they
enjoy and can do well at and make their
home life better or whatever it is that
we can do like but we're more assertive
we're more engaged and then that's
bringing us more pleasure so the
pleasure drive again it's not a
hedonistic drive it's drive for things
we enjoy like we enjoy safety we enjoy
absence of pain but we also enjoy
friends and romance and sex and food
like these are things that bring us
gratification and we can have that in a
healthy place too so there's not too
much and not too little of the
aggression assertion proactive drive not
too much not too little of the pleasure
drive and then we're in a place where we
can meet where those drives are at so if
the pleasure Drive is in a certain place
in us we can meet that right and maybe
we Foster it moving a little higher up
because we're doing good things and
we're taking care of ourselves so if our
romance is in a better place you know
then we can take more pleasure in our
romance right if our physical fitness is
in a better place we can enjoy that more
right we can do more things so we are
helping those drives to be in the
optimal place to subserve the generative
Drive which we are trying to optimize
and maximize and that puts us in the
best place to have the things under
those pillars in those Cupboards in a
good place and then on top of that
geyser is the empowerment in the
humility and then that gets enacted as
agency and gratitude and we have more of
the goodness of of peace and contentment
and delight and that reinforces the
generative drive so that's what's going
on and it has never failed me yet to
read or listen to
someone communicating happiness either
what they think it is how they found it
what they're striving for what they
think it philosophically is right it's
all that right and it's not as as simple
as a word right but because it's complex
we're complex but the beauty of it all
is the complexity is within us but it's
not
out of our reach to understand ourselves
better and help ourselves and if we do
that as we move further up the hierarchy
it gets
simpler approaching the world through
agency and gratitude as verbs and it's
pretty straightforward that's why that's
the best metric for romantic
compatibility right it's not this person
plays a musical instrument and that
person's a mathematician so they're not
compatible no more than one plays the
trumpet one plays the clarinet and we
assume they are compatible where are
those drives at are people healthy in a
healthy place we can then take the best
care of ourselves engage with others in
a healthy way understand who's a healthy
other to engage with right get ourselves
out of unhealthy situations and then
we're building Health within ourselves
and around ourselves and that's how at
the different levels of emergence things
get better so if I make myself healthier
and you make yourself healthier we will
be healthier as a group of two that's
always how that is and if we're
healthier as a group of two we can be
healthier as parts of larger groups
right or where if the groups aren't
healthy we're pushing towards greater
Health right we're engendering health
and that's how we see Health grow until
it can be manifest even on a cultural
level where we're taking better care of
ourselves we're less punitive we're less
rushing forward as a society and
trampling the vulnerable right and we
realize oh I could be the vulnerable
right I care about other people even if
I don't know them because I can
understand and empathize with what it
feels like to be vulnerable and
furthermore I could be among the
vulnerable so we behave differently as a
culture and that's what we're searching
for on an individual level all the way
up to a cultural level
I have several questions
um but first I want to just uh highlight
what you said about relational structure
relationships and the fact that
um as was explored in episode 3 and you
made so clear and it just makes so much
sense most of what people explore for
when looking for a romantic partner or
determining whether or not their
existing romantic relationship could be
better or not is focused on the wrong
things right these these very kind of
superficial Notions of what people enjoy
and even level of Education some of
which can really matter but that's not
the critical issue at hand and that the
maps that the two individuals have and
the extent to which they are expressing
their generative drive
and agency and gratitude is far far more
important and so for those that haven't
heard episode three and are interested
in relationships not just romantic
relationships but relationships of all
kinds work families relationship to self
friendship I highly highly recommend
listening to that conversation because
it's um it's truly spectacular in terms
of its actionable takeaways uh in by
actual well I mean actions of course
behaviors and also modes of thinking
that can really uh serve people I also
just want to make one clarification that
um I I believe that when you said
hierarchy when when you said move up the
hierarchy
um you were referring to the hierarchy
within the within the map that's been
laid out here right as opposed to I
don't want people to get
um uh mistakenly uh distracted by the
possibility that we're talking about
some sort of like external social
hierarchy
um so I just want to clarify that and
that's actually a perfect jumping off
place for
um going into the map with a little bit
more uh depth and detail and exploring
these cupboards that reside at the lower
levels of the map and that are quite
complex okay so for those of you
listening who have not yet gone and
access to the PDF that we put in the
show note captions
um you can do that at any point but what
we're talking about is a bunch of things
down at the bottom uh under these two
pillars structure of self and function
of self these cover cupboards excuse me
that are extremely valuable for any and
all of us to look in and explore and ask
specific questions because it's what
resides within those cupboards that
combine in a sort of recipe and then
geyser up into whether or not and how
much empowerment humility agency
gratitude peace contentment delight and
generative drive we are able to exert
and um and experience for ourselves in
life so imagine in your minds if you
will and here I'm borrowing directly
from a picture model that Dr Conti
provided before the filming of this
series which is an iceberg where below
the surface of the water resides a bunch
of stuff and then a little bit is above
the water and maybe you'll help us
revisit that model now for a few moments
but if you take nothing away at this
moment please understand that there's a
lot of complex stuff going on underneath
the surface of the brain and mind but a
key feature of this map is that well it
is very very complex underneath
what emerges from that complexity gets
simpler and simpler especially as we
move towards places of Better Health and
more Effectiveness in life so if you
would could you you know describe the
map in a bit more detail especially
what's down there in these pillars the
complex stuff and the stuff that we
should be looking at and then we'll
touch on some of those cupboards that we
all have and the sorts of questions that
we should all be asking in the context
of some common challenges but also some
very common and very effective paths to
doing and feeling better
yes yes now the the unconscious mind is
the place to start because that's the
deepest level of the structure of self
so imagine imagine sitting on top of a
biological supercomputer the size of a
house right that's what's going on
inside of us right the unconscious mind
is that biological supercomputer and if
we're interested in ourselves right we
become very very curious about what is
going on in it and and that's where even
though it's not directly accessible to
us it can be accessible through other
ways such as we talked about reflection
or therapy and of course there are other
ways too but it is accessible to us and
we want to know what is in it because
what it is in it has such a strong
effect on what's going on in our
conscious mind right that's the the
person on top of the
biological supercomputer the size of a
house or the the the image we've been
using is the top of the iceberg that's
coming out of the water so we can look
at that either way but what is in it has
of course a huge effect on the part that
we're aware of our conscious mind and I
think the best analogy here it's
actually I think quite a a an analogy
that parallels very well is to an
abscess in the field of Physical
Medicine so an abscess is an area of
Walled off infection right so imagine
that there's some infection for example
it's often in the abdomen okay there's a
there's some infection and that
infection could be really dangerous
right if that infection spread boy it
could go to the blood the person could
could die from that right so the body
does a really good job of Walling off
that infection right and and that's a
good thing right because if the
infection weren't walled off it poses
huge risk
but the walled off infection does not
represent a condition of Health
so someone who has an abscess in them
and doesn't know it this happens
frequently in medicine and we see people
coming to emergency rooms and you know
they have a low-grade fever and they've
had a low-grade fever for a while and
they just don't feel good and they have
low energy and they're not sleeping well
and they find themselves sweating a lot
they're a pervasive experiences going on
that are really detracting from life
like not feeling great all the time even
though the person doesn't feel really
sick that's sometimes why it takes a
while for the person to come to medical
attention so what's going on is better
than not being walled off but it is not
synonymous with health so what happens
in Physical Medicine abscess is
identified and then someone goes in a
surgeon goes in and drains it
and then the person is better right now
think about that process like surgery
surgery is not a fun thing right there's
anesthesia there's recovery right but
surgery is great when it cures the
problem right so it's not that oh the
the the the physician in the emergency
room or the Family Practice dog
identifies that there's an abscess refer
to the surgeon everything is great and
happy and they're better no they have to
go have a surgery and that's not an easy
thing right but if they go and do that
on the other side the infection actually
is gone so they do not have the symptoms
that it was constantly spinning off
inside of them and they also don't have
the risk that maybe that infection gets
out of the abscess and and their their
life is then at risk
so the the parallel is looking into the
unconscious mind to what is inside of us
that may be acting like that abscess
even though this is an analogy it is not
theoretical like this happens all the
time and the abscess inside that person
emotionally may be the bullying that
went on right around the time of puberty
right it may be that awful boss who is
just so mean and like took that good job
away from me right it might be that it
might be
you know that assault but I don't want
to think about that's really still with
me it might be that death I still feel
guilty about I don't know what it is
right but if there's an abscess in there
we want to understand it and then
fix it cure it right and that's what the
therapy process can do and that's why at
times the therapy is unpleasant you know
the crying and the anger you know that's
the parallel of going through the
surgery right but on the other side
we've dissipated the energy inside of it
like we've we've we've taken care of it
and and that's why it is so important to
go into the unconscious mind if there
are things that are really troubling us
or if we don't know what's going on to
cast the net of inquiry that may lead us
there because trauma is so common and we
shove trauma underneath the surface
because of the guilt and shame that it
generates and then it stays in us like
an abscess and Spins off symptoms they
could be symptoms of diffidence they
could be symptoms of overusing a
substance they could be symptoms of
avoiding good things in our life but
they're they're pervasive symptoms that
are really harmful to us that we can
understand and and fix
in addition to Quality therapy
what are some other ways to access the
unconscious earlier we were talking
about journaling and spelling out one's
life narrative in written or in spoken
form either alone or with a trusted
other let's assume that somebody either
can't afford or is just not at the place
where they're willing to do therapy yet
but they fully adopt this abscess model
that uh or this abscess analogy that you
described which I think is an
exceptional one because
um a you have the you know 20 plus years
of clinical experience knowing this
exists but also
um I think we all at some level kind of
understand that there's stuff happening
within us that we can't explain and and
I as a neuroscientist can absolutely say
that you know most of the neural
Machinery in your head uh and the parts
of it that are in your body like we
don't have access to it right we love to
think that we do but but we don't it's
just clicking away under there so let's
say somebody wants to
um make some progress
improve their level of mental health
more obtain more agency and gratitude
improve all aspects of their life and
their generative Drive what are some
ways that they can start to tap into the
unconscious
um and my guess is if it's not in
therapy it's going to be by looking at
some in some of these other cupboards as
you're describing them right yes develop
and embrace curiosity about yourself
right and if you can
go for that Curiosity being
dispassionate right in in the sense that
you know you talk about these files you
have with your with uh memories and
events from your past like that's so
good right because you're exploring your
life right so so someone who who wants
to understand themselves better do that
for yourself go look at pictures talk to
people you knew at different stages of
life reflect upon how you behaved at
different stages of Life what you felt
inside anchor yourself to memories and
then extrapolate from there become
curious about yourself and if you can be
dispassionate this idea that sometimes
gets called in observing ego right there
are other words to put to it but it's
it's not ego in a negative sense right
here it means the ability to stand
outside of oneself and go right and to
really think about oneself without the
negative emotion we're often able to
either see the trauma for example or see
the change like oh why did I
go from feeling really good about myself
and I felt like I could do anything and
then
just a couple years later man I look at
me I'm mopey in the pictures and you
know and I think yeah I was drinking
more I stopped taking care of myself
like that's a pretty big change right
and then so now like we're calling
attention what's that change and a lot
of times the person knew it you know
like oh I got rejected I had that
terrible breakup right and like they oh
they knew it was a terrible breakup but
they keep shoving it under the surface
maybe they didn't know it was a terrible
breakup maybe they can't figure out what
it is like that's okay wait even if they
recognize look there was a change then
that will put the lie to what in this
example is likely going on so that
person likely frames themselves in a way
that is very negative and always was
true right so so I could never achieve
anything I never feel good no one likes
me I can't find a partner whatever it is
we say to ourselves the person is it's
always been that way right because the
negative emotion is so strong and that
part of our brain doesn't care about the
clock in the calendar and then the
person goes back and thinks it was not
always that way
right and it comes to this a lot in
therapy doesn't have to be as you said
in therapy but no you know I was a
go-getter right again I'm thinking of
the person who said I was a go-getter
and I went out there and did things
which put the lie to her saying that she
was lazy and capable all those things
that were not true but she accepted as
truth right so she needed from that
mathematical perspective like to go back
and question the Givens right from our
perspective we're saying go look in the
unconscious mind go look in that part of
the pillar of the structure of self go
look there that's the deepest part the
most complicated part but it doesn't
mean we can't understand it and if we
start to gain understanding then we can
think more about the conscious mind like
wait a second what am I thinking about
what do I think about that right have I
really thought about this or is it just
running over and over in my head what
would I like to do about it maybe I'd
like to learn more maybe I want to go
get a book that I think could help me
listen to another podcast that could
help me talk to a friend like me maybe I
want to do those things so now the flow
between the unconscious mind and the
conscious mind right becomes much more
robust and that lets us look further
right to look at the next level up the
defense mechanisms that grow up out of
the unconscious mind and and we can have
some understanding of them even though
they're unconscious right so the idea of
wait what when that when something
shifted in me
how did my way of engaging with the
world kind of change you know like I was
perseverant and
um you know I would take some of that
energy in me that wasn't so good and
remember I could put it into like
exercising taking care of myself and
then you know then that sort of shifted
and I became sarcastic and cynical and
you know I started avoiding you know
those of my friends who are really
taking care of themselves and doing well
because that made me feel worse about
myself so so that's a dialogue that is
reflective of defense mechanisms now the
person isn't going to necessarily say oh
I used a lot of sublimation which is
good and then I started using reaction
formation and avoidance just as an
example right
but they're going to understand that in
in words that they can whatever words
they put to it they understand that
there was a change they can start
putting they put words to that they can
understand that process of change it's
not opaque they're Shining Light on it
and now they can gain a better
understanding of it and they can change
it even that realization that I was much
more functional things were different I
mean that can be a treasure Trove of
very relevant very important and very
positive information to bring to the
current situation I think we often
Romance the idea of the person who can
just live life forward who doesn't look
back who just doesn't really explore
their past it's just action oriented
because after all when we wake up in the
morning all we can control
so our action's going forward we can't
rescript the actions of past ours or
others right that is such a good point
of what happens when we're just looking
forward right we become like a sprinter
who comes out of the blocks too fast
right so if you think about the
beginning of a 100 100 meter dash right
they're the best sprinters in the world
say right and there they are in the
blocks and if they come out of those
blocks in the right way they will gain
momentum they will keep their form and
they will run as fast as they can but if
they do not pay attention to what is
behind them the blocks that are
supporting their body right the whole
bigger picture here of the limitations
within the body right they have to know
what those limitations are they have to
understand themselves that's how they
avoid coming out of the block so fast
and then sprawling headlong onto the
track and we see that happen too so if
we're just looking forward and thought
an idea that's how to live life we will
be tripping for and ultimately will be
like that Sprinter no matter how great a
sprinter if you come out of the box too
fast you're going to trip forward yes I
know I said this in a different form a
few minutes ago but I think a lot of
people are afraid of self-inquiry
because
they just don't want the thing that they
discover which resides in their
unconscious the abscess if you will or
the uh the damaging thought or thing
that happened which they are aware of
but are pushing down to take over their
daily life in a way that doesn't allow
them to be at least as functional as
they are in the moment if you go visit
the person who had the abscess cured by
the surgeon on post-op day one that
person will be less functional right
they'll be in a hospital bed right they
won't be able to get up out of the bed
they won't be able to exercise they're
going to feel they're going to feel
their best right that's okay right it is
okay that we at times can become
intermittently say less functional right
in the sense that we're more upset that
I'm spending more time crying right
that's okay because that's part of the
energy the effort the choice that gets
us to a better place
okay so it's clear to me why exploring
the unconscious mind can be and really
is immensely valuable it's just I'm
convinced and um I can't imagine anyone
out there who would disagree with the
idea that
getting better mentally being able to
function better in the world as a
consequence is not a terrific use of
one's time even if it uh you know at the
surface seems to take us off course a
bit in the in the moment or uh for even
a few days and I think it's also uh
worth highlighting that
it's not the case that if we do an
exploration of the unconscious mind or
look in any of these cupboards for that
matter that our entire day is going to
be overtaken by it or all of our sleep
is going to disappear I mean we're not
talking about
um a process in which everything is
devoted to exploring these cupboards I
mean there are instances of course where
someone hits a crisis and they simply
can't function but in that case the
thing they absolutely need to do is to
look in these cupboards yes what are
some ways that we can explore this other
cupboard under the pillar of structure
of self which is the cupboard of the
conscious mind
so we can also approach this through the
the Curiosity of self we do a lot of
things automatically right that we can
stop and think about like why do I do
that thing right and it's amazing what
that can
provide right so for example I'm working
with a person who has been going to work
for a long long long long long long long
time right didn't need to go to work a
long time ago right and there's so many
other things this person wants to do
with their life they're curious about
things they want to spend more time with
the older people in their family right
but they had to stop and think why am I
going to work
right now he's fortunate enough that he
doesn't have to he also earned you know
he's hard working he's diligent he's
fortunate but he hadn't thought about it
he's been going to work automatically
for a long time and it was the thinking
about it that made him realize well I do
that automatically now why because it's
rooted in in unconscious things but that
he's now bringing to the conscious mind
right because I value hard work and I
value diligence right but him stop
working doesn't mean that he's not you
know he's not innately hard working or
diligently showed that for years and
years and years and he can show it in
other ways like by you know how he wants
to be attentive to older people who need
help like there's a lot he can do but he
had to go back and look and then of
course there's a reason why he didn't
realize it right and even though it's
not even a bad reason but but clearly
there was then an overvalue of
hard-working diligent and he didn't
realize oh
I like I've done that right like I've
done enough that I've convinced myself
like I know I'm hard working I know I'm
diligent okay I don't have to sort of
serve that internal Master anymore and I
can step away and now his whole life has
changed but how'd the change come about
by asking what might one might think is
such a simple question to make no sense
like why do I go to work each day why
have I been going he's he's off on the
road to change so so that's it's one
aspect of of how we can explore the
conscious mind it often leads us back to
the unconscious mind right but it's
awareness of our conscious choices right
we can also then use tactics so for
example cognitive behavioral tactics
like thought redirection like if I'm
aware that hey there's a thought that
comes into my mind a lot and I start
learning ways I can redirect away from
it instead of thinking about it a
hundred times right and if I learn how
to do that there's less of a negative
emotion that comes from thinking about
it and and I can start to feel better
right it's the basic premise of it but
these are techniques that can really
help us and they involve understanding
and guiding the conscious mind
I'm smiling because I'm recalling an
experience I had I have a female friend
who a very impressive person really uh
has over comaton uh is a recovered
alcoholic for many years
um and takes at least by my read great
care of herself and the other people
around her and his spectacular sense of
humor and a bunch of other things but
it's probably five six years ago that we
were in conversation about something I
don't recall what and out of apparently
nowhere she she said I hate being busy
and it just stopped me in my tracks
because I'm somebody who
um keeps very very busy my schedule is
extremely full with things that I really
enjoy some things I don't enjoy or enjoy
less but um fortunately at this point in
my life mostly things that I enjoy at
the time
I was very very busy with many things
including many things I didn't enjoy and
her statement just halted me and I
realized you know maybe I don't have to
be busy like what this whole notion of
doing a bunch of things I don't want to
do like sure we have to make our way in
the world and make a living and take
care of ourselves and others but but I
realized that there was a lot of extra
stuff that I was doing right because I
think but what she meant and what you
were reflecting on was I hate being
automatically busy right right it's not
good to be automatically busy and then
it makes you think about wait how am I
busy in ways that are good for me and
how am I busy in ways that are not am I
just taking up time you know to avoid
something you start really thinking
about it yes and the conversation stays
with me to this day because up until
then I never really thought about the
possibility that some or a lot of the
things I was doing were truly a waste of
my time like it mostly because I could
be putting that energy into generative
things right generative tribes things
that would bring me agency gratitude
peace contentment Delight yes these
sorts of things what I'm giving as an
example I realize is quite different
than sitting down in a chair and asking
oneself questions about uh oneself and
and one schedule
same endpoint but it right same end
point and and I bring it up because
um I think it was the fact that it
stopped me in my tracks
but also the fact that I can't seem to
forget it that means that it must have
had significance and and I would say has
had significance because you know I
think most people are familiar with um
seeing these uh news articles that come
out you know you know woman or man you
know 104 reflects on what really
mattered in life and it's it's almost
always the same things it's like close
relationships it what you know no one on
their deathbed says I wish I spent more
time at work I might be one exception I
actually really enjoy my work so
whenever I see that one I always think
no like my life without my life's work
it would have been a diminished life for
me
um I think there are others out there as
well but I think it's very hard for us
to place ourselves into the future of a
person on our deathbed looking back and
then make really good decisions now I
think there are ways to do that but it
seems that it's far more powerful to
just think about what am I doing now and
and make some you know and come to some
realizations about what is really a
value now and what is of less value or
no value now out and then make
adjustments now because as opposed to
doing the deathbed exercise you have no
other option if you're going to make
change I mean think about what a
complicated and ultimately meaningless
exercise it is to try and project ahead
into a future when one is on one's
deathbed and it's like what is that like
like I mean we
can't imagine that and we don't know
who's there like whatever that situation
may be for any of us it's not going to
be what we imagine so then we just make
something up and we try and what
extrapolate our lives in a way that that
gets us to this place where we're on our
deathbed and we're not unhappy okay it
just brings us right Back to the Future
like because it's actually simple right
that is so complicated what are things
going to be like on our deathbed what
will happen between now and then all
things I don't know so it's impossibly
complicated so then you take it back to
the to the present right like what is it
I'm choosing I am the I right now that
is moving through time or is on the luge
of life or whatever we want to say so
what am I choosing right now that's how
we make our lives better and we're aware
of course I know there's a future I want
to lead towards a better future I can't
I don't have a crystal ball I can't
Envision what that's going to be but I
can do my best now to guide my life as
best I can and that's going to have to
Lead Me to the best future whatever all
the variables are that I don't know yet
the next cupboard under the pillar of
structure of self is defense mechanisms
I have several questions about defense
mechanisms but the first question is
can we be aware of our defense
mechanisms
and is there value in that and if so
which defense mechanisms are accessible
to us and I guess the third question
would be how does one go about exploring
defense mechanisms
well it's sort of Fantastical imagery
right that there's this Iceberg right
part is underwater part is above water
and then from the part that's underwater
come these sort of branches right so so
the way I imagine it is there there are
branches of ice that can be clear and
have light passed through them in a way
that is high fidelity right or they can
be sort of Twisted and unclear and they
distort the light that passes through
them now they Rise Up from the
unconscious mind meaning defenses are
unconscious they're automatic but
they're not outside of our ability to go
looking for them right they're in the
unconscious mind so so it's not that we
can't understand them is that they're
Elusive and there has to be a process of
inquiry but we can learn about them just
like we can learn about other things in
the unconscious mind and and here again
knowledge is power so
I'm not going to learn anything new or
I'm unlikely to learn anything new about
my defense mechanisms if I don't think
about them right but if I start to think
about them then I can start to learn
things and to draw conclusions you know
how am I behaving now as opposed to
before do I notice that like I'm coping
well often think coping but coping is
conscious but we can access that how am
I coping what am I doing and what does
it mean so so for example someone who
after some difficult experience right
then starts avoiding right can be doing
that without an awareness of it
avoidance is a defense so avoidance of
situations or people or potential
negative emotion right
so self-reflection can help us
understand which defense mechanisms
we're using and what may have changed in
us so an example an example we see all
the time is someone who say had as a
primary defense mechanism sublimation
before some difficult event then
sublimation is taking energy taking say
excess aggression turning it into
something positive right it's a good way
of handling distress within us it's
healthy right and now after some change
in their life they find that say they're
drinking more and they're they're
relying more and more on alcohol and he
might say Well they're soothing with
alcohol yes they're soothing with
alcohol in one sense but what else might
that mean right and oftentimes what
you'll see is maybe the person is using
alcohol because they're mad at someone
they're punishing someone that someone
is probably them they get to have the
short-term soothing but then to feel
worse about them themselves the next day
right and the alcohol is in part A
search for soothing but it's in part in
acting out against the self which is a
different kind of defense mechanism that
is not healthy so the process of
reflection or of inquiry can help us
understand
the branches that are coming up from the
iceberg from the unconscious mind how
are they in me are they arranged in a
way they're sort of elegant and and
they're clear and the light is passing
through them or are there things that
have become sort of Twisted okay what is
that what exactly is that how do I go
change that right I don't want that
branch that is sort of opaque and that
the light can't get through or is
distorted so so I can go look at that
because even though defense mechanisms
are unconscious if I'm working on myself
I can take away that so to speak
diseased Branch right or that Branch
That's not healthy and put in its place
something healthier that's how we can
change our defensive structure right
those branches of our defense mechanisms
because even though they're unconscious
right we can reflect on them bring them
to con to Consciousness and then bring
ourselves to Bear to make ourselves
healthier and it can indeed get
healthier and as it gets healthier it
affects the next level around it which
is the person's character structure so
remembering we're using Fantastical
imagery right because around the iceberg
blowing above the water and the branches
that come out of the part of the iceberg
under the water and how they array
themselves we're imagining that there's
a nest that's encompassing all of that
the unconscious mind the conscious mind
the defense mechanisms and that Nest is
the character structure it's a way that
we contain and Define the self that
rides on top of everything it is into
that Nest that the self settles and from
which the self grows because the
character structure is more than just
the conscious mind it's sort of the
conscious mind in action the defense
mechanisms in action all the things that
are going on underneath the surface in
the unconscious mind in action and then
that's how we be you think be as an
active word right that's how we are or
that's how we actively be in the world
how we're engaging with the world
so you describe the character structure
as the nest that is up above the surface
of the water and that includes things
like these unconscious defenses and all
other aspects of what comes from Below
then you also said that the self
ourselves reside in that nest and you
and I don't recall the exact word in but
you said something to the extent of you
know the self grows within that Nest yes
and as you said that I immediately had
the image in Mind of a nest that is
either incredibly nurturing and can
really Foster the self in its best ways
and can give rise to empowerment
humility agency gratitude peace
contentment Delight generative drive all
these wonderful things I also imagined a
nest that
um you know isn't as clean as it could
be or that has some holes in it or that
isn't stable in the wind and these sorts
of things is that sort of imagery that's
coming to mind for me is that a decent
way to conceptualize this yes and I
think this is a it is a very important
point the self nests in the character
structure okay and from nesting in the
character structure it grows we are the
self that grows from within that nest
and that tells us a couple of things one
I am something now right now
the things I've done the things I've
thought the things that have happened to
me like there's a self now so so one
might think then what grows out of the
nest right is what I am now hence the
concept of acceptance of self that's
what I am now right but I am also
responsible for tending
what is growing I'm responsible for
weeding it right I'm responsible for
planting healthy seeds in it and I think
that captures the truth of the
acceptance of ourselves this is what I
am now this is who I am now but isn't it
beautiful that I contend and nurture it
and we know as you'd come into what
happens if you don't tend it there's a
lot of weeds things aren't going well
things start to get unstable I mean
that's not good and we can go that way
too right that's where agency gratitude
you know part of how it all Cycles
through right because our unconscious
mind is still working like it's all
still happening and that's how we tend
that Garden of the self so to speak
that's how we best tend it so that what
grows up from it is a self that we
recognize in the way that we want to
recognize ourselves we see a self that
we can feel proud of we see a self that
we understand well enough to guide
forward we see a self for which we have
enough respect and humility within us to
understand that we don't understand
everything and it's from that self that
we engage with the world I've heard many
times before I'm in the circles of you
know psychology and self-help and
um elsewhere that you know
we need to all learn to mother and
father ourselves to some extent and I'm
not a developmental psychologist but my
understanding is that the unconscious
mind the conscious mind our defense
mechanisms the character structure all
the stuff that makes up the nest which
the self resides and hopefully can grow
our at least at some stage of Life
perhaps all stages of Life determined by
genetics and by how we were raised
nature and nurture but this phrase we
have to learn to parent ourselves it is
thrown around a lot these days
certainly on social media but elsewhere
too and oftentimes that brings to mind
sort of stereotypes of mothering and
fathering and these stereotypes break
down quite a bit these days
um things like you know we have to be
nurturing to ourselves you know
self-respect self-love self-protection
right healthy self-protection and these
kinds of things
um and all of that
sounds fine and good but it's always
seemed uh rather vague to me like you
know if I'm telling myself uh I'm okay
or you know is that is that mothering
and following myself like I don't know I
mean
um it doesn't seem as concrete as as
perhaps I would like and others would
like because
um because it's not spelling out to
specific actionables what you're
describing here
makes so much more sense to me even
though some of these concepts are a bit
abstract because the idea of this nest
in which the self resides and and
emerges from character structure
um one can immediately see why it's so
valuable and it's such a key component
of mental health and self-care to tend
to that nest and written into that is
the fact that the nest is malleable that
we really can make changes right that we
can create a better internal environment
for ourselves by going through these
cupboards you're pointing out another
crucial Factor here which is if I Am The
Garden of self that grows up from all of
it and I am responsible for attending
the garden I'm also responsible for
tenting to the whole structure
and that's so important if I'm going to
take care of myself in the ways that
we've talked about I'm going to attend
not just to the Garden that's growing
out that I can see on the surface but
I'm going to attend to All of Me to the
entire structure of self an example here
that I think can illustrate it pretty
well is so imagine a person who's doing
well you know the the part of the
iceberg under the water is solid right
the Consciousness on top is solid the
defense mechanisms are clear the nest is
good the garden of self is flourishing
and then there's a significant trauma to
that person there's a car accident
someone is hurt there's a death of
someone around them they have a serious
illness they lose a job right it can
even be they spent too much time
contemplating and looking at news from
murders around the world and all the
awful things that we can spend too much
time with something traumatic then goes
into the unconscious mind right the
trauma happens and what often happens
not always but what very often happens
is the guilt and shame that arrays cause
us to push the trauma underneath the
surface now that's in the unconscious
mind and it's impacting it and that
stability is threatened right I mean
it's all riding on top of this giant
part of the iceberg that's underneath
the surface of the water and okay we
don't have to worry too much about it
right if things are going well but if it
starts to get fragmented it starts to
shift it threatens everything that rides
on top of it which is why taking care of
ourselves means taking care of all
elements of the structure of self that
all makes very clear why tending to the
Garden is so key and why we as
individuals are really the people most
fit to do this right of course when one
can that work should be done with
somebody who's a really terrific
clinician help guide that process and
where one can't work with a clinician
one would hope that they would take a
structured approach to this which is
really
um what we're talking about here and in
the other episodes yeah and keeping in
mind because keeping in mind that
tending to the self
means tending to the whole structure of
self right if we keep that in mind we
won't go wrong right we'll pay attention
to the surface but we'll pay attention
to the things that are under the surface
we pay attention to the whole structure
of self we will Shepherd ourselves
forward as best we can
I'd love for you to tell us about
the function of self the second pillar
that resides alongside structure of self
and that serves to geyser up into how we
show up in the world hopefully with
empowerment humility agency and
gratitude but sometimes no and as we've
established there is always always
always tremendous value to exploring
these cupboards so how does one go about
exploring the different cupboards under
the function of self and we should
probably start that conversation by
um saying what are the cupboards under
the function of self
I'll start off by saying all the
cupboards under the function itself will
reference the structure of self right
which makes sense there's a structure
and the function arises from the from
the structure it's good for us to have
that in mind as we're thinking about the
elements of the function of self so the
deepest element let's say the the the
bottom of the pillar right is
self-awareness right the sense of an eye
okay on top of that next up the pillar
are defense mechanisms in action right
up from that is salience what we're
paying attention to inside and out the
next level above that is behavior and on
top of that is our stridings so if we go
back to the the bottom layer the deepest
most complicated layer it's the sense of
self-awareness the sense of an eye and
there are a lot of ways that we can
foster self-awareness so like the
unconscious mind in the structure we
can't just go there and fully understand
what the I is but we can do things that
can really really help us so for me
thinking about like what am I and how am
I navigating the world and having in
mind the structure of self like wait
there's an unconscious mind working its
away in me there's my conscious mind
even being aware of the first pillar can
be part of fostering the self-awareness
of the second pillar another way that
can happen is self-reflection for some
people it can happen in meditation
contemplation of the self right there
are many ways that we can help ourselves
understand that living is an active
process that idea of the luge of time
and where you know we're moving down it
it's an active process and that is the
eye that I'm guiding through that
process we can foster self-awareness in
a number of ways but what we're trying
to do here the same as with the the
bottom of the structure of self-pillar
the most complicated Parts there's a lot
that's unconscious there's a lot that's
unknown to us so what we're trying to do
is know some of it right and know more
of it over time bring some of those
automatic or unconscious things to
conscious awareness so that we can have
a better understanding because if we
have an understanding we can utilize
that to make everything better I can see
right off how this first cupboard of
self-awareness and then exploration of
the eye is so critical and realizing
that we have a physical body that we
have agency in the world to do at least
certain things
and in an earlier episode you mentioned
a practice actually of of looking in the
mirror and focusing on this reality that
we have a physical body we reside in it
and then we have agency we can do things
in the world as a way to reinforce
self-awareness such an interesting
practice and one that I I started on
immediately after well that evening yeah
and the next morning after hearing it
from you is some interesting things came
to mind and I encourage people to try it
it's it's uh done eyes open for just for
a few minutes or so two three minutes in
my case
um some interesting understanding came
about especially when coupled with
thinking about you know some of my life
narrative and things that have happened
so I highly recommend people explore
this this practice you described
I'm also interested in the sorts of
narratives that we have about ourselves
I think everyone has narratives about
what they're good at what they're less
good at what's happened to them why it's
happened to them
um could you tell us what you think
about exploring our narratives right not
just exploring the fact that we have a
physical body but exploring our stories
about ourselves well
self-awareness is just the awareness of
an eye right so we can use our conscious
mind to help that right so this this
aspect of function of self isn't about
what the narrative means right that
comes later this is about the awareness
of an eye so when you were talking about
the narrative you said something along
the lines like their stories and and
you're not thinking of like oh that's
it's the same me in in these stories if
if you approach the narrative in a
different way the awareness like there's
an I right there's a me like I'm the
point of all these stories right that's
why they're here they're all in me in
some way or another because I remember
them and they're important enough that I
wrote them down if you look at it that
way where you're just apprehending an
eye like there's a me to whom all of
this applies that's how we can use the
conscious mind and the narrative in
order to Foster self-aware this it's not
yet about meaning it's about the
awareness of an eye so it's actually
much simpler than I'm making it out to
be at some level at that level yes got
it yes okay well then at some point we
will return to this theme of narratives
narratives that serve us perhaps
narratives that don't serve us meanwhile
take us into that second bin under the
function of self the the defense
mechanisms in action I find these
infinitely fascinating and I think many
other people do too because
um sublimation uh denial these kinds of
things I you know they really provide so
much much of what does and doesn't
happen to each of us and um yeah so if
you if you could tell us how we can
think about our defense mechanisms in
action in a way that can improve our
health yeah yeah and of course defense
mechanisms are under the structure of
Mind defense mechanisms in action are
under function of mind right their
unconscious processes that we can gain
sometimes a very good understanding of
by directing our conscious mind towards
them and this is a place where we can
use narratives right we can use an
understanding of self so as an example
someone who's thinking about themselves
and what they want to do for a living if
they want their job or where they want
to live and you know who's thinking
about self can realize you know
he's gonna feel good when I'm doing
something for someone when we hear this
a lot especially people who then direct
themselves towards helping professions
like what did I like about that job it
wasn't that it had a great salary it
wasn't that the hours were good you know
I like that it was really helpful to
people or or you know there were people
that were underneath of me in the
hierarchy that I could really kind of
nurture right and then I think right and
I love putting food out for the birds
and the squirrels like it can be a
realization of self that guides us
towards consciously apprehending and
thinking about altruism as a defense
mechanism right because altruism is a
defense it's a healthy defense where if
you can do something good you do
something good make something good
that's the end point of it like you
don't need that to translate into
something else it's a defense mechanism
it's a good one and you can certainly
see how it fits with the good things
we're trying to build on top of it and
sometimes through that process of
reflection the person becomes aware of
that they haven't chosen jobs by the
obvious things that even they thought
they chose jobs by where is the job what
does it pay it wasn't that that what
they really valued and what they then
started choosing upon might have been
something that they weren't aware of
until they think about it and that leads
them to the defense mechanism the same
way another example could be
rationalization right someone who thinks
about their life and they think you know
I always kind of tell myself something
is better
than it is right and then ultimately
like I'm disappointing myself you know
like I tell myself like you're doing
really well at work and
you know I'm not really working hard
enough and then when I have that review
I feel lousy you know and that last
person who broke up with me and said you
know you just weren't being a reliable
partner or you know that person was
right right and that can lead to oh like
what's going on I always think things
are going pretty well
when they're not that's guiding us
towards rationalization as a defense
mechanism and again a person doesn't
have to say ah I conclude I'm using
rationalization as a defense mechanism
but there can be words put to that of
seeing a pattern in the self with his
when this is done as part of therapeutic
inquiry we're often looking to identify
the defense mechanisms and that can be
great too but it's not always needed
right defense mechanisms result in
patterns right so if a person just sees
the pattern that can be enough to
recognize the pattern and either say
follow the pattern of altruism as a
defense mechanism or how do we work
against how do I work against the
pattern of rationalization as a defense
mechanism
can we conclude that patterns that we
don't like
are the reflection of unhealthy defense
mechanisms and that patterns that we
like are the consequence of healthy
defense mechanism usually yes at least
worth some thought and some reflection
in putting together like what exactly
are the pieces of that but basically the
answer to that is yes
in an earlier episode you mentioned one
defense mechanism in action that is
often observed in people is acting out
you know this immediately sounds like an
unhealthy defense mechanism
um so to keep with this concept of the
patterns are often more observable than
are the underlying defense mechanisms
would it be the case for instance that
if somebody you know has a repeated set
of failures like that's that's a pattern
or is um
repeatedly in friction in a particular
relationship in their life like maybe
even just with one person like all other
relationships are going great but then
they're in a lot of friction with this
one other person so there's a pattern
from that pattern they could explore uh
what uh I mean is it important that they
get to a uh verbal identification of the
defense mechanism or um you know what
what sorts of
steps would one take going from a
recognition of the pattern to
understanding of the defense mechanism
perhaps in a way that moves them forward
the understanding of the defense
mechanism can be very helpful but isn't
always needed right if you can recognize
a maladaptive pattern like oh this is
happening a lot and it's not good for me
you know you you become able to change
that pattern right so understanding the
defense can be helpful I mean again the
more understanding the better but it's
not always necessary here I think to
understand the the defense mechanism we
should first Define acting out because
we think of acting out just hearing the
words as something that's volitionally
done right but that's not what we're
talking about right defense mechanisms
are unconscious so there's an
automaticity to the response that the
person can see by reflection because
this isn't conscious choice to act out
that's something different that's bad
behavior right but what we're talking
about here is the thing that's automatic
and unconscious until we bring it into
our conscious mind and acting out isn't
always dramatic either so so here's one
example right so let's say in a
relationship situation right you have
one person who always does the dishes
the other person does something
different right that person does the
dishes right and you know it's onerous
people have busy lives it's owners have
to do a lot of dishes and and every time
like things aren't going so well there's
a little bit of conflict between them
right the other person makes twice as
many dirty dishes
right this is exactly the kind of thing
that happens in relationship situations
where this little thing becomes a little
crack in the door that opens more and
then there's a foot in the door now
there's a big problem because we act out
in these ways that we're not aware of so
again the person isn't deciding I'm
going to do that so that that person has
to do more work but there's an
automaticity to it and and upon
reflection sometimes a person could
realize I'm doing that right or it's a
real example person who realizes
I just make much more difficulties
right around the house like I make a lot
more difficulties for my partner whoa
you know like this person doesn't want
to be doing that right that's not they
love that person they don't want to be
doing that but by realizing that when
they can bring a process of change of
just being more self-aware and saying
look I don't want to do that I don't
want that to be a defense anymore
if I have conscious awareness now I can
control it and maybe that person is
doing that other places maybe Chris is
you know it kind of goes that way at
work
two you know I could contribute to a
project and make something easier on a
person and I realize I don't do that
right if I'm if I'm feeling some
negative way then we can go find okay
what might the roots of that be did it
for example did a parent role model that
behavior right was that done to them
where the parent was really good to them
if they were behaving in the right way
and like they make their breakfast right
and if not well you know you make it
yourself or oh sorry there's no milk I
mean like these things happen and then
the person gets in them some array of
circumstances feelings responses all the
stuff that goes on in the unconscious
mind that then throws up to the surface
this kind of acting out as a defense
mechanism so I think it's it's important
to point out and it's a good example
because it is unconscious and a lot of
times how we're doing it is not dramatic
what about salience you know this
cupboard under the function of self that
I think we are all all too familiar with
uh you know like what we pay attention
to internally and externally
I have a sort of bizarre meditative
practice that I've talked about before
on the podcast I don't know why I came
up with this but it's more of a
perceptual exercise that I do from time
to time where if I feel like I'm too in
my head I literally Focus my visual
attention outward I try and place it on
a horizon or some object out there
um and other times if I'm sort of in the
world too much and I want to get back
into myself I'll you know close my eyes
and do a moment or two or more of more
traditional what traditional meme what
people think of as meditation the
practice involves
setting aside a minute or two and
deliberately stepping through uh closed
eye
meditation like just it's not really
meditation again it's just recognize
myself like here contained within my the
skin of my body then I open my eyes I
look at my hand this all sounds very
silly as I describe it but but and then
I think about a bridge like my
perception can be split between my
awareness of self internally and my hand
then I look out some distance 10 12 feet
or so
um and do the same as a bridge to
self-aware bridge self-awareness with
external awareness and I step out to the
Horizon and then I sometimes like to do
the exercise of um it goes with a
popular meme you know this so we're just
like this like pale blue dot I think
about myself in in right here but then
the fact that I'm on a planet that's
like spinning and you know in space and
and then right back into myself and then
I go about my day
um uh and I developed that a few years
ago more on the basis of what I know
about visual perception and interception
our recognition of inside versus extra
reception just fancy language for
recognition and and perception of what's
outside but that's my practice of of
orienting myself in life
um because then I feel like I have a
better buffers against what happens
around me and how much I'm reacting or
not reacting that's my practice
um I don't I have a feeling it it
touches into a few of these bins
um but not but it certainly doesn't get
it at you know approaching a specific
problem or thinking about where problems
might exist beneath the surface that I'm
not aware of right because it's only one
part of the equation right it's paying
attention to sailing and see what you're
doing then you are grounding yourself in
order to change salience
right and and that is a strategy you
said oh maybe it's silly or this or that
no it's an it's an understood and known
strategy for example variations of that
are are what people can do to prevent
panic attacks right to change the
salience if the salience is I'm going
inside of me and I'm feeling panicked
and I just you know I just have a
feeling of awfulness right you can
change that salience by grounding
yourself to the world around you right
we tell people place your place your
hands on the table look at the specifics
of exactly what time it is look at the
shape of a doorknob right ground
yourself so that you can change salience
because now as we move up the hierarchy
of of function of self we're getting to
using the conscious mind right things
that are Salient to us can be external
they can be internal and if they're
internal they can be conscious and
sometimes they're unconscious so it's
not all about the conscious mind but
we're bringing the conscious mind to
Bear here to think about salience which
combined with everything else can help
us see see what's under the surface most
of the time what we're doing is that
active self observation right what is
going on inside of me which can be what
am I thinking this is how the person can
realize over and over oh my goodness I'm
saying to myself
X and for the first time they say out
loud and realize the thing they've said
to themselves ten thousand times right
or it can be a feeling state right wow
what's Salient to me is a feeling State
say of vulnerability and then everything
seems threatening right so salience it's
a it's a form of self-awareness that we
can could say is using the conscious
mind now to tend to that Garden of self
right to look at that Garden of self and
say what's really growing from it right
is it all things I like right it's gonna
be never all things we like because it's
a process but am I happy with it am I
not happy with it are there you know
weeds that are coming up all over the
place those that could be the intrusive
thoughts right so we're using metaphors
but it's actually very very concrete
right the salience part is what is going
on inside of me and that's a very
interesting inquiry and informative
right it's interesting because it's
informative
do you think that's an inquiry that's
best done in meditative like States you
know set or setting aside some
deliberate time to
um to think about like what am I
thinking about what am I paying
attention to how am I allocating my
thoughts yeah or my thoughts being
allocated I guess we have to respect the
unconscious component here like we're
not we don't just walk around saying
place my intentional Spotlight there and
then my thinking here you know we always
want to be aware of what we that there
are things we don't know that's
respectful that's appropriate humility
because it's true so I'm assuming this
ratchets directly into the cupboard of
behavior right
um you know what we're actually doing
um is that covered best explored by
listing off perhaps on paper in our
minds what we're doing each day is that
is that one way to explore like how am I
spending my time
um again not as a an efficiency exercise
but as a way to start to explore the
self and and
um and the mind uh for sake of building
up to more agency and gratitude right
right you know the routes to to most
effective self-inquiry right to bringing
the conscious mind to Bear really differ
widely by person there's some people who
they're so well served by doing that
when they're meditating right there are
other people who like they can really
get at that when they're playing a sport
you know it's going on inside of them
along with the other things you know
that they're that they're doing some
people find it in the shower or they
find it when they wake up in the morning
or they find it when they're with an
animal they love or they might find it
when they're reading a certain kind of
material and then they read it and then
they kind of the reading Trails off and
they're thinking they're a reverie sort
of inside so how we can engender the
best use of our conscious Minds is going
to differ by person but again we can
think about that like what really works
for me let me do more of that someone
and it's interesting we see people
sometimes I see people a lot of the time
who are they're trying to meditate to
understand themselves and it's like not
working right and it's like I must know
how to meditate in order to understand
myself well it's not necessarily true it
might be I must go on more hikes in
order to better understand myself
because that's how it works for me so
that process of reflection can be very
very helpful to us because we're using
our conscious mind to try and either
look inward what is sailing it to me
including understanding that I don't
understand everything but I can
understand a lot of it and outward what
behaviors am I engaging in what are my
behavior patterns right and to be
reflective about that to think about
that can be immensely helpful to us like
how am I spending those hours of the day
what am I doing with my time am I way
wasting my time do I always get mad and
say something mean to somebody why
because I had a negative thought about
something am I doing that no have I kind
of changed since something unpleasant
happened and you know now I'm not so
nice to someone in the household right
or am I taking a lot better care of
myself you know like since I started
doing X whatever X may be learning more
about myself right uh doing more of the
things I like got left that old job it
was so hard for me to leave you know I
do actually get myself to the gym right
so it's a reflection upon self because a
lot of what we do we do automatically
right and that's very important right if
you know the example that often is given
is okay think about how you last brushed
your teeth right and the answer about
like a blank right because you brush
your teeth in an automatic way right
most of us don't remember that because
we just skip right over it so it makes
sense it lets us us think while we're
doing things it lets a lot happen
automatically in the physical world
right just as it happens inside of us
automatically but we can there have sort
of too much of a good thing where too
much is happening automatically and we
want to stop and think and it's
remarkable how sometimes when people
stop and think they might say like real
examples I don't want to be spending
five nights a week at the bar and I'm
spending five nights a week at the bar
why because I go home a certain way from
work and there's a bar along that way
and then I think oh I'll just stop in
and maybe see a friend and then I know
that once I get in there I'm going to
have a drink and I know once I have a
drink I'm going to get three and I I'm
gonna have three and I see this pattern
of behaviors and how like I don't decide
I'm going to go to that bar instead of
going home to see my wife or my husband
or my kids or whatever it may be and I
don't want to behave that way right
because they are that's a it's a great
example of how you can stop that from
happening but once it starts happening
The Dominoes start falling it's very
very hard the people don't generally
realize oh my goodness I'm in the bar
and I've had one drink and now I'm going
to have two more that's not the time but
the understanding the reflection upon
Behavior patterns can lead a person to
stop those behaviors to understand and
recognize them get their arms around
them Shine the Light of Day on them and
then have greater agency right and
greater gratitude I'm grateful I can go
home to my family and that's what I
choose to do right and I can do that I
do not have to end up at that bar and
I'm not going to end up at that bar I'm
going to drive a different way home and
if I can't get myself to do that I'm
going to have a friend in the car with
me and if I can't do that I'll be in the
back seat right but I'm not doing that
thing I choose not to do and you know
that's a it's a more dramatic example
not an uncommon one but we can apply
that the whole way up the list from
nuances of our behaviors down to more
dramatic behaviors
I've heard you describe
the unconscious mind and some of its
other
interconnected workings with the analogy
of a you know a phantom in the driver's
seat and we're in the back seat sort of
you know of course all within one person
right this idea that we're just being
taken place is that we don't want to go
or that we know we shouldn't go or that
we can't really figure out why we're
going there and we have some idea but
um we're just not certain about what's
going on you know it's it's not
necessarily
um related to really um destructive
action either I mean it can be but what
you're describing sounds to me a lot
like uh climbing out of the back seat
and um maybe sitting in the passenger
seat and looking into the uh driver's
seat you're like oh like there's
something else going on here of course
all of this is one mind
um and
in doing that taking some control of the
vehicle right it's about understanding
what is that Phantom where did it come
from that's how we get rid of it like
how do we get back in the drivers see we
don't grab the Phantom and throw it out
the door or throw it in the back seat
right it's it's ephemeral we can't grab
it right so how does it go away it goes
away through understanding so very
common example that the Phantom in the
driver's seat is trauma that we have
pushed in an unconscious place and now
that whole under the surface structure
of the iceberg is is fragmented and a
sort of roiling and there's a big
problem there and if we go at that
problem and whatever it's spinning off
right that's the abscess but it's a bad
one and it's spinning off a lot of
problems and that's why the Phantom is
in the driver's seat because healthy
things are not built on top of that
fracturing and roiling part of the
iceberg right we see that a lot right
the Phantom could also be something
different it could be one defense
mechanism that's unhealthy that we are
really over we're relying on and then we
can understand it through that lens so
there's just a few examples but if if
you know if we sort of wake up in the
back seat of the car so to speak and the
Phantom is driving recklessly then how
we get the Phantom out of the front seat
is by understanding it then you know I
always imagine proof it goes away
because now it's not driving my life
anymore
right I'm driving my life it's gone
the message that I'm hearing over and
over again in my head is that uh no
matter how well or how poorly
any of our Lives happen to be going
that by looking in these cupboards under
structure of self and function of self
we can have so much more
positive control yes
yes that's why ultimately what we're
talking about is optimistic I mean we
can't help ourselves if we don't honor
truth right and the truth is that there
are complex aspects of this so okay we
want to go look at that we want to look
at how things can go wrong and that's
all very very important but that's all
wrapped in the best truth which is that
we can change it we can make it better
that's why the self The Garden of self
is on top of the structure of self right
and the top of the function of self are
our strivings that's what comes next
after behaviors it's like what are my
behaviors doing what am I doing what am
I striving towards what am I doing
literally am I going to a job I hate am
I doing things I don't want to do am I
accepting treatment that I don't want to
accept am I treating people in ways I
don't want to accept how can I strive
for better and striving and hopefulness
or so in intertwined so the Pinnacle of
the function pillar is striving the
Pinnacle of the structure pillar is self
and we can see how the self the
strivings right what we're doing now is
combining the pillars where it comes
together and you know your imagery of it
that's where the geyser comes from and
we want that geyser to be healthy right
it's a stream of clear clean water
that's coming out of it that's where our
empowerment is but empowerment is a
condition of being right I am empowered
empowerment rests within me that's where
humility comes into the picture humility
also something within me right I have
humility they're not verbs but
empowerment and humility then gain their
expression at the top of that geyser
when agency and gratitude those verbs
arise from empowerment and humility what
you've drawn from US is an incredibly
compelling picture because the the
picture with the map is really a road
map
it's a path to ideals and um and you've
been talking about these ideals of
agency and gratitude across this series
and um they just Encompass so much and
as you mentioned before they are
interconnected and they are verb States
and a critical component of the
geysering up from the pillars toward
agency and gratitude
are these two components of empowerment
and humility and tell us a little bit
more about empowerment and humility and
how we should view empowerment and
humility
in the context of self-care
empowerment is a state that we can
create for ourselves if we're taking
care of the pillars right so we're
looking in the cupboards we're doing the
things that make our map clear and
clearer right this idea that oh that
seemed like a good path but it gets
clear and there's a swamp there right or
that didn't seem like a good path
because it's circuitous oh no but there
are good things along that path so the
map gets clearer as we tend to the
cupboards in the pillars and that
empowers us right we're in a state
there's a state inside of us that is a
state of potentials that are now skewed
in a good way right that's what
empowerment is it's like it's not
something that happens it's a state that
we then bring to bear on what happens
right the same is true of humility now
humility does not mean not acknowledging
things that are good about you right and
we often can can very much
mischaracterize
humility like is that person being weak
is it false humility or people often who
are conscientious don't want to
acknowledge good things about them oh no
no I'm not that smart like that's not
humility right humility is consistent
with truth right so if you keep saying
you're not that smart but the world
around you tells you that you're that
smart right then acknowledge that you're
that smart right that's coming through
the lens of Truth and right when you go
down to the pillars and the cupboards
and say okay how does a person get to
acknowledging that truth right so it's
only by by squaring away the things that
humility isn't right it is not
denigrating ourselves and and we see
that in a lot of people I'm humble so
and then the person often tells you why
they're accepting something that's not
good to accept right so humility is
about acknowledging truthfully the
characteristics that you have within
yourself good and bad and here is where
we can identify things that we're not so
happy be with right we have to have
humility within us in order to make
ourselves better right just like I have
to say look I'd like to be more fit if
I'm going to then get myself
in a more fit state right so saying look
I can be no I can be a little bit so
snippy with people if I'm irritated or I
can be a little bit condescending or you
know I can
um I can be a little selfish at times
but it's hard to admit these things to
ourselves but if we have the humility to
to acknowledge those things right then
we also get to have that broader
humility about just being a person like
wow look how complicated this is to
navigate life I mean these pillars are
not simple and when we go down to the
the real base elements of them it can
get very complicated so then we have a
compassion right for self and for others
you know like sometimes I'll say to a
person I should be doing this I should
be doing that they think they should be
doing something perfectly and I will say
to them it's amazing that that we're
moving forward right I mean let's start
with with wow it's not easy to be human
it's not easy to navigate this world and
that kind of humility can then allow us
to feel good about what we we build on
top of it right it's not easy to
navigate this world and humans are
pretty vulnerable by and large but I'm
applying myself right and and I'm proud
that I'm applying myself or that I'm
perseverant but also I'd like to be a
little more compassionate like it's that
sort of thing that combines with
empowerment so empowerment and humility
are these potential states that then
Express themselves or become enacted
however we wish to put that but they
change into the active verbs of agency
and gratitude and agency and gratitude
are ways of being right they're verbs
they're active so that's the point of it
from the sense of how we are living
right how we are being that's why agency
and gratitude is in some sense its own
endpoint right but because there's a
circular aspect of this right our active
being is not the end point if word being
in a healthy way then we get to
experience things right peace
contentment Delight we experience them
because we are healthy so we get to be
through the lens of agency and gratitude
we get to experience peace contentment
and delight and that makes a healthier
us the drives and their expression are
in better balance the generative Drive
is fostered and strengthened and the
drives underneath of it the aggression
assertion proactive right we're really
using that in a good way and we're
mining all of it within us like I want
to bring that to bear and I can bring
more of it to Bear right that's very
very good and the pleasure Drive is
active in us I'm enjoying the things I
do I feel good about the things I do I'm
making good choices and that state of
health what it promotes the pillars the
cupboards to stay clean and clear and
healthy right but Life Is Life and the
slings and arrows of Outrageous Fortune
the slings and hours of life will
continue to come at us and cause us to
go back and look at the pillars and the
cupboards and even if they don't come at
us those things are never perfect right
but that's not bad because by tending to
them where do we bring ourselves we
bring ourselves back to the active verbs
of agency and gratitude the active verbs
of living and here we are in this cycle
that if we pay attention to it we use it
to understand ourselves we use it to
improve ourselves can bring us to Better
Lives
how do you think about a person
and I've confess I've been this person
um perhaps still am to some extent who
can really
have a sense of agency and gratitude in
certain domains maybe even many domains
of life
um and yet feels as if there are certain
areas of life that are just so much more
challenging than others by this like
stark contrast like this stuff works can
do that but like this stuff is just
really really hard
um and maybe that continues long enough
that it almost starts to feel like or
the person wonders whether or not you
know maybe that part of life is
inaccessible to me it's just never going
to be successful for me
um you know how do you think about these
um carve outs of of you know
functionality and lack of functionality
that's probably not the right language
but
um I think this is important because uh
it relates directly I believe to the
kind of narratives that we tell
ourselves I mean they are narratives
right I think it's important to think
about these because
um you know they are intermeshed with
and perhaps even the consequence of
narratives that we have like stories
about ourselves that we have internally
um and again you know I'll be the first
to admit that uh I've felt this way for
much of my life
um certain things I can do other things
far far harder and sometimes it felt
outside the reach of possibility
I have a very concise answer to this one
in fact it's nine words
don't make yourself special in ways that
hurt you
and we tend to do that as humans oh I
get to have a b and c but I don't get to
have D I get to have professional
success and I'm in pretty good shape and
I have a lot of friends but I don't get
to have a relationship I mean over and
over and over because the relationship
part is so emotionally Laden it's the
part that gets carved out right falsely
carved out the most right but it can
happen in any Arena of life where we
make ourselves special in a way that
really is black magic or is being cursed
right you have the Machinery right the
ability the function to to go about
pursuing the things you want and get
them right that sounds like a pretty
good paradigm accept about something
really important to you right that can't
be right it's we're applying the same
Machinery of self because we're talking
about the things people want in a broad
scale right like I would like
professional success I would like
personal success I would like to do well
in my family unit and be a good family
member I would like romance right so
we're talking about areas of self right
and we will make ourselves Special by
carving out one and then applying black
magic or some cursed state that then
takes that away from us and that creates
tremendous consternation that will throw
all of those Cupboards in those pyramids
off balance because like we don't like
that like that seems mysterious and
ominous you know what is there that you
don't know that's about being cursed so
you can't have something and then that
makes anger and frustration in us and
more likely that we'll act out or we'll
be frustrated and we start enjoying
things less right sometimes a person and
can wall something off like that and
they can go forward with the rest of
life you mean it affects them but it's
not obvious it's not on their mind all
the time which is why the process of
self-inquiry can reveal important things
like oh like I pretend that I don't even
care about professional success and it's
the only why do I do that it's the only
thing I'm not doing very well and
because I think it's it's impossible for
me it's not something I get why because
I got other things so I don't get that
okay now we're we're really curious
about that and sometimes it causes very
very big problems where a person who who
a person can build an external sense of
self that soothes some of their
vulnerability so they can present in a
certain way but underneath of that
they're hiding the sadness or the pain
of what is missing but that is then sort
of eating away at them and their
feelings of self on the inside don't
match what people see on the outside we
see a lot of this and the process of
self-inquiry of self-exploration of
curiosity about self can lead us to
realize what we've carved out if we
don't already realize it or it can help
us to see that the carve out makes no
sense right it's as if you said well
you know there are nine roads around my
home and you know they're all just
regular old roads I can drive on eight
of them but not the ninth
and he said well it doesn't make any
sense if there are they're similar it
requires the same set of skills right in
order to drive the car and the visual
Acuity why wouldn't you be able to drive
down the ninth but even though that's a
very mundane example but it's that that
we apply to very important and
emotionally charged aspects of our life
you know I get to have physical fitness
and friends and Career Success but I
don't get to have love I mean we hear
people say this and that's a very
powerful way of taking us away from what
we want to achieve in life it takes us
away from the active agency and
gratitude and all the good that comes of
that
what you just said makes a lot of sense
especially the point that uh you know if
we have nine roads around us and we can
drive down eight of them why not the
ninth
um because it places us back into the
verb tense and the action tents of like
the car like we're a vehicle the eye
that we can take through the world right
sure conditions matter maybe Road Number
Nine has Boulders on it
um but you know it can't be that roads
one through eight were all just smooth
super highways either right those had
challenges and uh
we I'm not going to use myself as a game
I for whoever is doing this sort of
exercise
um had a mind that was able to work
around those Boulders right of
challenging people of uh you know
limited finances of um these are all
things I've experienced you know and of
course people come into the world with
different levels of Challenge and
privilege and accessibility Etc we don't
want to deny all of that but but those
other eight roads are rarely if ever
perfectly smooth roads that's why it's
completely about the self right and it's
the realization that if I brought myself
to bear
and I got down
the first eight I can bring myself to
bear and get down the knife and as
you're pointing out it's not like the
first eight were easy right maybe one of
them was really pretty smooth right but
there's going to be a couple of them in
there that are have have raised really
you know strong difficulties things to
surmount and to overcome and it's from
that place of understanding that we find
within ourselves the Courage the
strength to go down the ninth Road even
if we see greater barriers even if we're
okay I'm aware now but I'm also aware
that I avoided that ninth Road for a
reason right the boulders and the
potholes right they're more severe on
that road in fact I'm kind of worried
that it's that it's impassable but I
mean it can't be impossible right if
there's Boulders there I'll you know
I'll go rent some Excavating equipment
or I'll fill in the potholes right and
and that's how we get ourselves to go
forward and tend to acknowledge and
validate like I'm afraid of doing that
if I weren't afraid of doing it I would
have done it already right but I now
realize like what the truth is and what
I brought to bear in the first eight and
I'm going to bring myself to Bear for
the night that's also when we recruit
often resources around us we might say
Let Me Tell a couple good friends about
this or a clergy member or a therapist
or you know a trusted other and let me
explore this more in myself and and
that's often how in in making ourselves
better we we engage more with the people
around us and then the support from
someone else that may help a person do
that right is support given back to the
other person and this is also how we
build the Beyond self is that the the
path to travel down the ninth road so to
speak we don't have to travel alone you
know much of the time but that off then
almost always wasn't in the person's
mind right they they perceive it's a you
know three-person job you know to go
down and say great you have two friends
yeah certainly where I've been able to
travel down certain roads
um the key features have been a desire
to go down that road
um a recognition of the landscape but
not trying to take on the whole thing
all at once
um and then finding really good people
and and frankly really trying to avoid
people that
seemed uh you know poisonous to the
journey right that we're going to you
know throw toxic things into the engine
of my vehicle and and that's putting a
lot on them but
um you know it just felt as if going
down those other roads was too valuable
an expedition to spend time on and with
people that it
wasn't helpful to spend time with
um and at the same time there have
always been good people that have
presented themselves with
um examples I think you know this is
where it comes to mind you know it's not
always the case that you know you got a
friend who's saying you can do this and
here's why we're a therapist that says
you can do this and here's why but that
um they're examples in the world of like
well this person did this
um I think when we have challenges in a
certain domain you know that ninth road
so to speak
um I know for myself that I know I'm in
a place of of futility when I start to
um reflexively Orient towards others
that have had a problem getting down
that road you know like oh like I
recognize this other person who's been
good at roads one through eight but not
nine
um and it occurred to me during the
course of the series really that
um you know why not pick different
examples so if you're going on a journey
and it's a really important journey and
it's a difficult Journey but it can be
awesome bring good people
right have them on your journey be on
their journey and then you think well
why would a person not bring good people
if I were going on a journey and it's
going to be arduous but wow we could see
amazing things along the way I can I can
bring a couple people with me I don't
want to choose a couple people who are
lazy you know some who you say you know
don't look at the world around them and
you know some that won't uh be helpful
to somebody else in needs like why would
one
choose that right it comes back to the
self right if a person now we're talking
about any Journey right this is the
Journey of life right if a person is
choosing people you wouldn't choose to
be on the journey with you it's because
you don't think that you're worth better
right and if you think that you're worth
better you won't choose the people
you'll say I want other people like me
I'm going to be diligent perceptive
collegial Cooperative so I'm going to
surround myself with people like that
and if we if we look Beyond ourselves at
groups of people and at culture the
healthier we are the more we align with
healthy people and the more healthy we
are because we're making ourselves
healthy we get healthier groups of
people the journey is better for all of
us and this is how we can make the whole
culture better right potentially this is
how we can make life on the planet
better but it has to start somewhere so
it has to start with the eye
I love love love the message that you
know if you're heading off on a journey
that's really meaningful to you know go
with and make sure that you interact
with good people uh this is actually a
place where
um you know a reference to social media
and online communities is actually
um worthwhile and can be very beneficial
you know I think it's easy for us to
kind of roll our eyes at like self-help
and things like that on the other hand
there are communities online that I
consider myself a part of but for which
I and many other people have derived a
lot of strength a lot of
um reassurance and confidence right you
know because a lot of people are
isolated they might have access to one
or two people in their community that
they really value but those people are
perhaps also busy with other people or
um I can remember being a student alone
in my studio apartment as a as an
undergraduate I'm feeling very much
against the grain of my local
environment you know too much partying
for me at the time meaning I wasn't
partying and there was a lot of partying
around me and had I been a better
student in high school I probably would
have been able to helpfully engage in
that but I just wasn't able so feeling
pretty isolated but knowing I was on a
path so in that case it was one
Professor one graduate student and a
hell of a lot of books and music that to
me just carried me through you know
nowadays I'm fortunate to have many more
uh direct resources in my life of
amazing people but I I just want to
mention that because I think in this
discussion around self-care and um the
various practices I think there are sure
to be people who are you know that that
kid that woman that man that's you know
like alone in a room then you're like
okay but how right I I see the the
grocer once a week and I and I see my
neighbor and they don't even say hello
you know and and um you know how to
start to access some of these better
connections right navigating the online
world is navigating the world right it
comes down to understanding and choice
so if we're understanding as best we can
we're making Choice as best we can then
we'll find great things online they're
great things to find online same is true
of life if we're searching for something
that for example allies us around hatred
around acting out around things that
make us unhappy even around
commiseration instead of thinking about
how we can make things better right then
we bring ourselves in a different
direction that's life if we understand
and we choose as best we can we will
lead ourselves to better places
such an important message and is a
perfect segue into a question that I and
I'm certain many many other people have
about anger and you know not just anger
from interpersonal conflict like
somebody said something and it really
upset me but stuff that we see stuff
that we observe in the world could be
um uh acts against other people words
against other people or you know that we
take reference to and I think many
people feel yanked around by
um you know even dragged uh by something
they see and and they can't get it out
of their head now there could be all
sorts of reasons related to each and all
of us why we can't get it out of our
head work that we need to do Etc
but according to the map of mental
health that you've laid out for us
things that get in the way of that
generative Drive are really quite
poisonous to our well-being and the
well-being of the world because that
generative Drive is about learning
creation and yes it tends to be
pro-social yes and uh in so many ways
tell us about anger and how from a frame
of reference of trying to engage in
self-care
we should think about our anger and work
with our anger in ways that can perhaps
even help us and not harm us
in order to really understand this and
this is so important we have to Define
three words right and the word to start
with is affect so affect is aroused in
us right meaning we don't have control
over it so anger is an affect it is
aroused in us the idea being that if a
person is walking down the street and
someone jumps in front of them and
shoves them anger is aroused in them
they don't choose to be angry in fact
the body reacts and has all sorts of
fight-or-flight responses before the
person even realizes that they're angry
so we can't control what is aroused in
Us in the immediate term we can in the
longer term if I have a short fuse and I
get angry really easily you know I can't
really control that in the next 10
minutes right meaning the affect that's
arousing I can do different things with
it but I can't change what's created in
me but if I'm living a better life
taking better care of myself the
generative Drive is better expressed I
have more pleasure in my life then what
happens is the mechanisms that arouse so
much anger start to arouse less anger so
by taking care of ourselves we arouse
less anger but anger is aroused in us
okay the next word is
feeling right and again there are
different definitions for these words
but the way we're defining them affect
is aroused
feeling is when we take that affect and
we relate it to the self it's the next
thing that happens on the way up because
the arousal of affect is very deep in
the brain as it comes up the next thing
it does is relate that affect itself so
this is where that the classic example
of a person who spills something they
are angry that thing is spilled it
raises anger in them then they become
aware and they match the anger to self
and say what a dummy right what a jerk
I'll never do anything right they say it
inside right because the anger gets
enacted against the self now what what
how would we like that to go where the
person is taking better care of
themselves so when they spill something
less anger is aroused and by the time it
gets to Consciousness there's less anger
so it's easier to manage and there's a
stronger sense of self all the other
aspects of the pillars and the covers
are are in a good place then the person
is better able to manage what anger
makes it right to feeling and then to
say
you know okay everybody spill something
now and then whatever then to clean it
up and the person doesn't have to enact
the anger towards themselves right so
affect feeling and then emotion so
emotion is when we relate the affect and
the feeling to others in the world
around us so for example a person might
spill something and then it arouses
anger and now they get to the feeling
part but they have a set of unhealthy
defenses and they don't think they're
responsible for things they're
responsible for so they just keep that
that load of anger right that that
affect upwards until they get to emotion
and then they decide that wasn't my
fault it was yours
and that's why maybe they kick the dog
or they slap somebody or they say
something mean like this happens so if
it happens a lot like this is part and
parcel of what's going on in us a lot
about negative emotions I mean there can
be dramatic examples but they're smaller
examples that are winding their way
through our lives and the better we take
care of ourselves the less aroused
negative affect we have and the better
we cope with it when it gets to the
level of the eye and when it gets to the
level of the you right and if we think
about pro-social collaborative behaviors
versus the inaction of anger on a large
scale right if by the time it gets to
you there's still a lot of anger there
it is very easy to then paint with a
broad brush right oh the problems are
that demographic right the problems are
those people who aren't like me right
that's where anger is at its most
dangerous so the idea of having the
negative effect under control having the
understanding and the control mechanisms
right keeps us from getting to that
broader level the level of you and then
working in ways that are not pro-social
but are anti-social and and this I think
also relates to what we can find online
right we can find online everything we
can find in the world so then we have a
choice are we going to work on
understanding what choices are we going
to make about how we're engaging in the
world and if we're choosing the good
things we're taking better care of
ourselves and we're better so the
citizens of our relationships of our
family units and ultimately of our
societies
I've observed anger directed my way
certainly I'm far far from perfect I
have thousands of flaws and I've
directed anger towards others in ways
that I wish I hadn't
um a common observance I've had about
myself and others is that when angry a
lot of valuable time is wasted instead
of placing my efforts within the
generative Drive creating things that I
really value the anger becomes an
immense distraction you know and I've
seen this a lot um not just on
University campuses
um but one place I have seen it is uh
when I was a graduate student or postdoc
there will be some interaction for
either between them
um in the laboratory I was in although
rarely
um but more often it was about some
interaction with uh between a student or
postdoc and someone in the outside world
and so they'd come in and they'd be
really upset about it and there's a
tendency to you know try and support one
another which I think is healthy but
then it was like that this would just
continue and continue and the person
would be like sitting in their chairs
like really upsetting and sometimes
these were really upsetting occurrences
that warranted taking some time and just
really stopping but often I felt like
things just kept spiraling up and
spiraling up and it's like halfway
through the day and again I'm not immune
from this but but I observed it more
than I felt it certainly
um it's like wow that's a lot of time
wasted like they just
days or perhaps even weeks and months
and then there's the Sleep loss that
goes with anger
um I think that's one of the things
about social media and online
communities that's new and unique is
that it used to be when kids went home
from school or we go home from work you
would something might have happened
there but you didn't have access to more
incoming
um you know people weren't calling you
on the phone telling you you know things
that you don't like or talking about
others in ways that you don't like
whereas all you have to do now is pick
up social media and if you're not really
deliberate in how you interact with
social media and on the internet and
which news articles you read and which
ones you you scroll past I mean that
could be accessible at two in the
morning when you're up about the thing
that was angering you during the day
that is new right and and and requires
elevated levels of of diligence right
high levels of anger bring volatility
and confusion right and that doesn't
serve anyone or anything well lower
levels of anger can be healthy right I'm
angry at that and I and and I want to
try and make it right or I'm angry at
that and I'm going to have my say and
I'm gonna have my vote in it or whatever
it may be lower levels of anger okay
they can inform us they can guide our
behaviors but when we get to high levels
of anger it's volatility and confusion
the person ceases to then be effective
and here's an example when you were
telling me about how you feel when
you're doing the solo podcast right and
and how your agency and your gratitude
are like really in action and you're
feeling you know you're feeling the the
peace and and you're delighted and you
the generative Drive is at the fore in
you right and then I said what if we add
a little bit of anger even right to kind
of make you and then your response is
like oh it would all come offline right
because there you're doing something
that calls for like you to really be at
your best firing on all cylinders so
even a little bit of anger is too much
but it's a good example because it shows
like you're able to do this thing that
that is so good for you you're living in
the place like if you could have all of
existence be like you feel then right
you would love it you could bring it to
all the rest of your life like that's
the Nirvana where we're going for and
you're actively living it
but we could throw it off and ruin it
with even a little bit of anger right so
it's an example that kind of models for
us how higher levels of anger cause
problems in situations that are not so
rarified as that high levels of anger
make sure somebody blurting out somebody
attacking somebody somebody saying
something they shouldn't somebody making
a bad decision you know anger isn't good
for us at high levels and we can
decrease it by making ourselves
healthier that then we make less of it
and we control it better and we keep
ourselves at the low to moderate levels
of anger hopefully low again no anger is
not good high anger is not good let's
try and live in the low range
occasionally something is very
distressing We rise up to moderate
that's where we have anger in a healthy
place
when we set out on this uh journey to uh
explore what is mental health
I had no expectation
um that you would deliver to us this
incredible map of how to explore our
inner territory and that you would spell
out such crisp and clear ideals
um of states and ways of being in things
to access
um nor did I uh know anything about the
generative drive and the other drives
that reside within us you know in
thinking about self-care
um and in thinking about the sorts of
things that people are challenged with
often you know I made out a little list
not just anger but things like scared
embarrassed grieving dejected tired
confused stuck you know and then I wrote
you know infinite number of these right
I mean there have to be an infinite
number of challenges that people face
an infinite number of circumstances
and
perhaps even an Infinite combination of
those things that people face in
circumstances that can make it all seem
like a giant oppressive Cloud within us
and around us
and yeah what you've provided is really
a um uh a path of clarity because it's a
path that
certainly includes a lot of complexity
down in those pillars at the bottom you
know the structure of cell function of
self
but you've directed us toward looking
into that complexity looking into those
cupboards
as a way to arrive at answers that bring
us toward more Simplicity you know
empowerment humility agency gratitude
peace contentment delight and this
incredibly uh attractive thing uh the
generative drive that that is really
accessible to any and all of us
it's there and every one of us
in providing this path of clarity and
again I want to remind people that
whether or not you feel you're doing
well in life
um maybe even in all domains of life or
whether or not you're experiencing
challenge in any or perhaps even all
domains of life
going into those cupboards is clearly of
immense value and you've so graciously
spelled out how we can do that
regardless of resources really uh it
sounds like all it requires is a desire
to be better and feel better and do
better and a a willingness to to explore
curiosity right if I had to summarize
the whole thing in two words I would say
be curious right because curious opens
the door to all of it curiosity about
self curiosity about life
leads to all the good things
well what you've given us is of immense
value and it's something that I know
that I and um many many other people are
going to take on as uh as a positive set
of goals not just for
immense challenges but really for always
right for living forward and
understanding the past I mean I
um never before have I
um been presented with something that
felt like it had as much power and
potency to do good as this so that's
great I'm happy to hear that well it's
absolutely true and um I really want to
thank you uh on behalf of myself and and
everybody else for you know sharing with
us your your time your intellect your
willingness to build this structure
specifically for this series
um and it uh for lack of a better word
it's it's so generative it's a thank you
and um and I'm sure that people will
have tons of questions
um and tons of experiences of their own
to share in terms of using this and they
can share that with us and that's one of
the wonderful things about podcasts is
they can put those to the comments on
YouTube or or elsewhere we're really the
comments on YouTube would be the place
to share those questions and comments
and feedback and um
and perhaps going forward we can explore
the self the psyche relationships and
ways to improve all of that and our
lives
um going forward yes yes this has been
great it's been invigorating and fun and
thank you so much
thank you for joining me for today's
discussion all about true self-care with
Dr Paul Conte this marks the ending of
the fourth episode in our four episode
series all about mental health with Dr
Conti you can access each of the
episodes by going to hubermanlab.com
where it's linked out to all formats and
regardless of whether or not you have
now completed or you are still in the
process of digesting the material from
this series I hope you found it to be as
enriching and as useful in your life as
I have and on behalf of myself and Dr
Conti I want to thank you again for your
time and attention if you're learning
from and or enjoying this podcast please
subscribe to our YouTube channel that's
a terrific zero cost way to support us
in addition please subscribe to the
podcast on both Spotify and apple and on
both Spotify and apple you can leave us
up to a five-star review please also
check out the sponsors mentioned at the
beginning and throughout today's episode
that's the best way to support this
podcast if you have questions for me or
comments about the podcast or guess that
you'd like me to consider hosting on the
huberman Lab podcast please put those in
the comment section on YouTube I do read
all the comments and if you're not
already following me on social media I
am hubermanlab on all platforms so
that's Instagram Twitter LinkedIn
threads and Facebook and on all those
platforms I discuss science and science
related tools some of which overlap with
the content of the uberman Lab podcast
but much of which is distinct from the
content of the huberman Lab podcast so
again it's huberman lab on all social
media channels not on today's episode
but on many previous episodes of The
huberman Lab podcast we discuss
supplements while supplements aren't
necessary for everybody many people
derive tremendous benefit from them for
things like enhancing sleep for hormone
support and for Focus if you'd like to
see the supplements discussed on the
Hebrew and Lab podcast you can go to
live momentous spelled ous so it's
livemomentis.com huberman if you haven't
already subscribed to our newsletter it
is a zero cost newsletter called the
neural network newsletter and in the
neural network newsletter you get free
podcast summaries as well as tool kits
the toolkits are brief PDFs that list
off the specific science-backed
protocols for things like improving your
sleep improving Focus optimizing
dopamine deliberate cold exposure we
have a complete summary of our fitness
series again all available completely
zero cost you simply go to
hubermanlab.com go to the menu scroll
down to newsletter and provide your
email to sign up we do not share your
email with anybody thank you for joining
me and Dr Paul Conte for today's episode
and last but certainly not least thank
you for your interest in science
[Music]